Hello everybody!
Hello, hello!
Oh my god, okay, I was so ready to start.
Guys, I swear to god, I was so ready to start on time.
And then literally, my phone died because I forgot to plug in my phone to my charger.
And then I was like, oh shit, so I had to wait for it to turn back on.
And then when the moment turned back on, I was like, I'm so ready.
And then I got a phone call.
And I was like, who's calling me?
Who the fuck is calling me?
If I have a phone call, somebody must be dying.
Like, I swear to god, you only call me if I do not answer phone calls.
Unless someone is fucking dying.
So I was like, okay, who calls me?
Everyone just texts me.
And then I took the call, because I was like, you know what?
Today I'll feel nice today.
Usually I would leave it to voicemail.
Or voicemail, because I was like, if this was important, they would leave a voicemail.
Because then it would be telemarketers, you know?
I was like, it has to be telemarketers.
Because if it was important, they would leave a voicemail.
But today, I was like, you know what, Doki?
Your apartment is now clean, and I feel great today.
By the way, I slept, I went to bed at 8pm today.
I went to bed at like 8pm.
I woke up at 4 in the morning to put up my waiting room and post my tweet.
And that's why the waiting room came up at 4 in the morning.
Also, I had to, you know, walk dad.
Because I was like, oh fuck!
Usually he gets his walkies at like 2 or 3am.
And then I set an alarm, and I woke up at 4 in the morning.
But he didn't wake me up.
I think he was just like, I guess we just sleep.
Because when he sleeps, he goes full hibernation mode as well.
And then he's like, alright, guess I'll sleep as well.
Because he didn't wake me up either for walkies.
So then I woke up to give him his walkie.
I guess it's also daylight, oh you're right, daylight savings time.
It's technically 3 for him.
Like his body is like, oh you're right, I forgot about daylight savings.
Technically if daylight savings wasn't a thing, it would be 3 in the morning.
Also my bra broke, I just realized.
Sorry, TMI.
Okay, so for those who are men, who don't know.
At the bottom of the bra, it's a metal strap thing.
And like, this is an old one too, by the way.
This is TMI, I'm sorry.
But like, for education for the men out there about bras.
It's not sexy!
Because at the bottom, there's a thing called the underwire.
And like, it's an old bra.
So like, it's like several years old.
And so like, there's a metal thing.
So when it snaps, there's a fucking metal rod poking at me.
And it hurts.
And I was like, oh shit, did this break?
And then like, it hurts a lot.
So there's an underwire at the bottom, and it's metal.
And it pokes you and it can stab you.
So like...
So, what the fuck?
It's very uncomfortable.
Anyway, it's broken now.
So that means I'm trying to like, fucking...
Like, you know, I'm doing a lazy...
Like, have you ever...
For the women out there who does like...
Like, who used to do P.E.
and everything.
And like, you know how like, you're a bit embarrassed about like, taking your clothes off in the ladies changing room.
So you like, try to do it like, underneath your shirt.
And everything.
I'm doing that to take out...
I'm not taking my shirt off.
I'm just like, doing it inside.
It hurts.
Alright.
Very specific.
That's how I took off my bra.
Oh my god.
Ow, that actually hurt.
That thing was like, poking me.
Like, I don't know.
It just like, broke.
I think it broke when I was sleeping.
Sometimes I sleep with my bra...
Yes.
Apparently it's weird.
No, I think it...
I didn't notice it while I was setting up.
But then like, while I sat down on my PC.
While I sat down on my...
No, I'm not bleeding.
It's not...
It was...
Okay, so like, there are cases where the underwire can break through the fabric.
And then like, poke you and make it even hurt you more.
But it didn't break through the fabric.
It literally...
I think it literally like, just broke.
So like...
So like, it didn't break through the fabric yet.
But it was still very uncomfortable.
But anyway.
Yes.
Apparently it's weird to sleep with your bra on.
But I did that so much.
Like, I don't know why.
I just grew up doing that.
So it's just like...
Because I...
Okay, guys.
I have other women friends, guys.
I...
Guys.
So like, you know.
I would be like, yeah, I sleep with my bra on.
And they're like, you sleep with your bra on?
And I was like, yeah, is that weird?
And apparently that's fucking weird.
And...
No way.
You're not just a bro.
Bros don't wear bra.
Well, some bros do, okay?
I'm sorry to tell you this.
But your bros are fucking women.
I'm sorry to break this news to you.
Yeah, so like...
So, they're sleeping bras?
Wait.
Okay, but I'm too lazy to have bras for separate occasions.
That's so weird.
Like, I just wear it.
And then we'll just go...
I think it's also because I'm just too lazy to take it off, I guess.
And then put it back on.
Like, that's like...
Look, my laziness transcends everything.
So it's like, why do I have to take it off when I can just leave it on for the next day?
Like, that's...
That's how my brain goes.
I was just like, why?
Like, why the fuck would I do that?
Because if I take it off, then I have to put it back on when I wake up.
So like, why the fuck would I do that?
I can just sleep with it on.
So it removes extra steps to my routine.
Anyway, but now I realize why people take it off.
Because it breaks very easily when you sleep with it on.
Invictus, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hi Doki, it's me again.
I love your Lord of the Rings stream as it's my favorite franchise.
Hopefully you will continue it.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
I might just go with...
If I do play, like, Lord of the Rings, the RTS game again.
I will play...
I might just go with the second game instead of continuing the first one.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Dear, welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Cas, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
If the bros are wearing bras nowadays, then I gotta get one too for my bro.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Nexy, Doki...
I changed clothes!
I'm just saying, if, like, if I take a shower in the morning, I'm gonna take it off then.
Or, like, later.
So, it's just convenient.
It's convenient, guys.
It's convenience, okay?
I'm just like, well, it means I was just, you know, I won't need to actually, like...
Guys, come on.
It's just basic convenience chat.
Nexy, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Guys, guys, guys!
No!
I changed my clothes!
I literally just did laundry, chat.
I literally just did laundry.
Don't fucking do this to me.
Don't...
Don't do this to me.
I just did laundry, guys.
I put two pies in my laundry.
It was, uh, it was a lot of laundry.
I have to admit, it was.
But I have a lot of clothes.
It's because I have a lot of clothes, chat.
I have, like, a lot of clothes in my closet, okay?
So, I just put, whenever, like, you know, I was like, it's time to put this in.
Because I don't, I don't, technically, I don't have a laundry basket.
I just, like, if I have to, you know, if I have dirty laundry, I just stuff it in the, um, I just stuff it in the washer instead of putting it in a basket.
And then, at one point, when the washer starts getting, like, a little full, I be like, it's laundry time.
And then, I just do my laundry.
Hehehehehehe Oh, Wolfhound, shower clothes offer max convenience.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Um, Nexy, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Couldn't just not wear one to sleep until after you shower, though?
Nexy, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Well, you see, Nexy, sometimes, I wake up at 1220.
And then, I have to stream.
So, I can't do a morning shower, guys, because of that.
And then, sometimes, because I wake up at 1220, and then I have to stream, um, I, sometimes, I have to go out after my stream to walk Dad.
So, after I walk him, I do the shower.
So, that's why I can't just, I can't just wake up and shower, because sometimes, I schedule a 1230 stream, and then the moment I wake up, it's streaming time.
Do not, and waking up earlier is not an option.
Um, normal size, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Doki, when it rains, oh boy, I finally, I can do laundry.
Thank you for the super chat, normal size, thank you, thank you.
Doki, what do you mean I'm caretaker?
I have stream, I have a set schedule, chat.
I have, I have a set schedule.
Alright, anyway, so after I put my waiting room and everything, I obviously went to bed.
I went back to sleep, and I woke up at 1220, I was so fucking tired.
Also, like, it's over for me, because, um, I started dreaming about Marvel Rivals games.
Like, I was in a ranked game, and I was like, it's over for me.
Like, there's, there's no cure for this brain rot anymore.
When you start dreaming about, about it, it's over.
There's no cure, guys.
Anyway, um, um, wait, what else?
Oh, yeah, cleaning, I forgot to talk to you about my cleaning lady story.
Uh, anyway, so, um, so, uh, because I didn't talk about it yesterday.
So, I realized how, how much the cleaning, the cleaning lady, because at first I was like, ooh, it's $200 Canadian, by the way.
I couldn't tell if $200 Canadian was expensive for cleaners.
Because, like I said, I've never had a cleaning lady come in and professionally clean my apartment before.
It was my first time hiring one.
So, I was like, I don't know if it's expensive or not.
Because, like, um, they charge, I couldn't tell.
And, um, so, because, uh, I, when I, when I was like, oh, man, how many people are coming?
And they're like, only one person is coming.
And, um, and so, like, when she came over, she was like, where do you want me to start?
And, obviously, I was like, the bathroom.
Because I felt like, you know, that's where all the fucked up shit happens in there.
Pun not intended.
But, that's where the biggest problems lies when it comes to cleaning.
And then, I was in my, I was just like, uh, also, um, dad did not like her.
Uh, because, like, I guess, because, like, usually, I guess he doesn't like her because she came.
I usually, uh, he likes women.
But, like, for some reason, he didn't like her.
And I think it's because you could tell she's afraid of him.
Um, because I was like, oh, I have a dog, is that okay?
And she's like, yeah.
And then, like, when she came in, he, like, came over.
And then, she, like, started, like, blocking him from her legs.
And then, that pissed him off because she, he was like, I wanna smell your legs.
And then, I was like, and then, and then, like, I think that, like, pissed him off.
Because he's like, why are you afraid of me?
Why won't you let me smell you?
So then, he started, like, barking at her.
And then, he was like, he was like, why?
Why won't you let me smell?
And then, so, like, why are you running?
So, so, like, um, so, like, I had to pick him up and, like, lock him in my bedroom.
Because, um, because he was being a little freak.
And so, so, and, like, obviously, he was, like, making her afraid and stuff.
So, I was like, I'm so sorry.
Like, he's usually, he usually really likes women.
So, like, I am sorry.
And I think he didn't like that she just, like, intruded on, like, his home and everything.
So, um, so, then, um, um, so, I was like, I'm so sorry.
Uh, he's usually really friendly.
And then, so, yeah, so, I had to lock, so, anyway, while I was, like, waiting in my bedroom so, like, he could be comfortable.
Um, obviously, he wasn't that comfortable because he's, like, what is she doing outside?
And why won't you let me smell her?
And,
um, look, I know it, okay, now that I think about it, that was a little rude for me to say.
But, like, I, I, I was, I was tired.
Okay, I was, like, tired and I was, like, panicking and I was, like, I don't know what to say.
And I was, like, I was surprised that he didn't like her.
Uh, but, also, he smelled, like, he knew she was afraid of him and he didn't like that.
And he was, like, why are you afraid of me?
I am a good boy.
I am a good boy to women.
Why are you afraid of me?
And he did not like that she was afraid of him because he's so used to, like, women liking him.
Um, anyway, anyway.
So, she spent an hour plus in the bathroom, just cleaning the bathroom.
And I was, like, um, I was, cause, like, she was booked for four hours.
And I was, like, oh, man, that's a long time cleaning the bathroom.
I'm, like, oh, oh, man.
No, it's a very small bathroom, guys.
It's, like, it's an apartment bedroom, a bathroom.
So, like, so that's why I was, like, man, for an apartment bathroom, an hour plus is a while.
But it's so clean now.
It's actually crazy how clean it is now.
Um, and then, and after she was done in the bathroom, she was, like, wow, you have a lot of hair.
Because, because I told you guys, I grow hair really fast.
Like, my head grows hair really, really fast.
So, like, um, obviously I shed a lot when it comes to hair.
So, I shed a lot from when I, like, shower and brush my hair.
Like, she even, like, okay, it's so gross.
She even, like, um, she, like, basically, uh, because the floor was, like, there's lots of hair on the floor and everything, too.
So, uh, please, stop.
Um, and so, like, yeah, so, like, and, okay, here's the gross part.
She even, like, unclogged, it wasn't, technically it wasn't clogged, but for women out there, you know the problem.
But sometimes, you know, like, the drain covers catches hair and stuff.
So, she even cleaned that.
And I was just like, oh, man.
It's true.
Yeah, yeah, so, like, you know, like, the, the thing, like, the thing where you, where you push down and then you can make a bath and stuff like that.
And then you put, you take it out.
And then for the women out there, when you take it out, when you take out that, that thing, the cover thing, and then you see the hair and you're like, oh, God.
And then you're like, let's pretend that doesn't exist anymore.
This is also, yes, but for women, we have very long hair.
It's a lot worse.
It's a, it's a lot worse for women.
Because we have a long hair.
It's hard to see it.
So, yeah, she even, and then, you know how, it's very funny because guys can, okay, that's true.
Guys can have long hair, too.
But, like, not a lot of you guys.
So, like, it's more common for women.
Anyway, so.
So, anyway.
Anyway.
And then she, like, proved to me, like, I don't know why it was just proof that she's like, yeah, I did that.
Like, she, like, took the thing out so I could see that it was clean now.
You don't know me, Doki.
Yeah.
Bros can have long hair, too.
What the fuck?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
So, she took it out so I could see that it was really clean.
So, I was like, whoa, she even did that?
Anyway, it's crazy.
She did an amazing job.
Because she even cleaned my shoes.
I was very surprised.
She cleaned the bottom of my shoes.
Because I, like, went up to ask if she could do my office as well.
And I just see her, like, holding my shoes and cleaning it as well.
And I was like, oh my god.
She cleaned my shoes, too?
Oh my god, she can do everything.
Yeah, above and beyond.
I was like, what a...
$200 well spent.
That was actually so worth it.
I didn't have to pay extra at all.
That's crazy.
I didn't even have to pay extra.
You know what's even crazier?
I didn't even pay the next other 50%.
Because they haven't sent me the bill yet.
I just paid the first 50% before she came.
And then I messaged them.
I was like, alright, thanks.
That was great.
When do I pay the next one?
And they still haven't sent me...
They haven't even sent me the other 50% bill.
Like, I can't even pay it.
And I was like...
I was like, okay, it's been like several days yet.
And I still haven't paid the other 50%.
I might text them back because I think they forgot about me.
But I'm definitely going to...
I'm definitely going to...
I'm definitely going to hire them monthly.
Because, like, wow, that was very convenient.
Like, it was honestly incredibly convenient how...
How great it felt right after she finished cleaning.
Because I was like, wow, I feel like a different person right after.
Like, I don't feel like I'm living in Filth anymore.
It wasn't that bad, guys.
Before the cleaner was here, it wasn't that bad.
But, like, still, it did feel really nice.
Like, the floors are clean and everything.
And, like, she did the dishes for free.
And, like, the bathroom has less hair in it.
It was not that bad, okay, guys?
It was not that bad.
But it felt nicer.
It did feel a lot nicer.
Mr. Sen, thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you!
Because usually they charge...
Can you pass on the cleaner for a job well done?
Thank you again!
But usually...
Usually they said they charge extra for washing dishes.
But because she had time...
Because she had time, like, she was able to do the dishes for free as well.
So I was like, yippee!
I don't have to wash my own dishes!
Yay!
So, yeah, that makes me...
I was really happy about that.
Anyway, so today...
Okay, back to the...
Back to the game now.
Yoshi, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Doki, is this game worth buying?
Also, are you gonna try the roguelike warriors game?
There's a roguelike warriors game?
Wait, what?
The roguelike...
My opinion on the game so far...
It's the best dynasty warriors game they made in the last...
15 plus years.
If I can...
Dynasty...
What was the last one?
Dynasty warriors...
9?
Was it 9 or 10?
I don't remember.
9.
Okay, 9.
9 was the last one.
And the last...
Uh...
I think it's the best one so far.
In a lot...
Warriors Abyss.
Warriors Abyss?
The fuck is that?
When did this come out?
I never heard of it.
February 12th.
Oh, it came out last month?
I've never heard about it.
Um...
Is it fun?
That's 806...
It has a very pause...
I've never heard of this game.
Is it fun?
Abyss is really small but really fun.
I'm not a huge fan of the graphics so far.
I'm not gonna lie.
It's Dynasty Warriors...
What does SW mean?
It got Shadow Drop.
Yeah, I've never heard nothing about this game before.
Um...
But yeah, no.
The only issue I have...
The only issue I have regarding the Dynasty Warriors...
Oh, Samurai Warriors.
Oh, I've never played Samurai Warriors.
I've never played Samurai Warriors before.
Um, I...
The only, like, hack and slash...
The only hack and slash Warriors game I played was just literally Dynasty Warriors because of the three kingdoms.
Um, so I've never played, like, the other Warriors series before.
Not even the Zelda one.
Um...
Oh, that's a lot of...
I don't like the graphics though.
But I guess it's like a game where you don't care about the...
Like, you don't focus too much on the graphics and more on the gameplay.
The graphics...
Okay, let's see.
Initial thoughts.
Sadly, this seems the same.
It's not worth the price I've mentioned so far.
Phase 1 to 7 lasts about 10 seconds each!
HAHAHAHA!
HAHAHA!
Okay, that's funny.
HAHAHAHA!
Absolutely ridiculous game from SlappyButternut.
Um...
HAHAHA!
5 stars!
HAHAHAHAHA!
Um...
Also...
Okay, so this is a lot of fun for a good price.
If you're not a fan of Musou Warriors...
There are way better Hades-like updates.
Oh!
So it's like...
So that's like...
It's basically like Hades.
But for Dynasty Warriors.
I see.
Maybe I'll check it out.
Maybe I'll check it out next time.
Um...
But that's interesting.
I feel like they didn't advertise this game at all.
I've never seen anything about it.
Um...
Is Hades 2 way more complete now?
I'm gonna wait until Hades 2 fully releases.
Before I actually play.
Because when I play Hades 2...
I want to play it in its entirety.
You know, chat?
I just want to play it until completion.
Because I don't want to play it where I have to stop somewhere.
Where I have to stop somewhere and wait until the next chapter to be released.
Because I want it to be a full, long series.
Um...
No, it's not fully released yet.
They're like, slowly adding more and more content to the game until they finish...
Until like, to completion.
Um...
What else did I want to talk about?
Fuck!
I had something else I wanted to talk about but I forgot.
Uh, bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu...
Sorry, um...
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Sorry, I can't say...
I can't.
Oh...
Oh my god.
I'm sorry, I can't say what I just saw, because NDA, but it's pretty cool.
Oh my god, I'm freaking out.
I wish I could say it!
Fuck!
Okay, I can't.
I hope this gets approved.
I hope it gets approved.
Oh my god!
Holy shit, okay.
Okay, we're cool, we're cool.
We're cool.
We're so cool.
Jack, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Have you ever thought about playing NieR Automata?
Also, I gave my first super chat two streams ago, and you didn't see, so I ask again.
Nandoki, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, so sorry to see your very first super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Oh my god, Nandoki, you mean Priestoki.
Okay.
I'm here.
Repent, repent in super chats, guys.
Are you here to repent, Jack?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Just tell us if our wallets are in further danger.
PapaSmart, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I don't know.
Asumi, thank you for your very first super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
When will you have one eye, so you can be hard like Xiaodong?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Guys, I don't think I'm chuny enough, chat.
I'm not chuny enough to have one eye yet.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Your very first super chat.
Oh my god, I just realized.
Ah, fuck.
I remember what I wanted to talk about, and then I forgot about it again.
Fuck, okay.
The phone call.
I forgot to talk about the phone call, though.
So the phone call was actually...
For those who are wondering what the phone call was, the phone call was basically one of the cleaning services that I tried to reach out to, but never got back to me.
And then, like, I literally said I needed a cleaner at Sunday.
And then they called back to me, like, today, and was like, do you still need cleaning service?
And I was like, no, I needed it on Sunday.
I don't need it anymore.
So, yeah.
That was the phone call, and I was like, I knew I shouldn't... I knew I should've never picked up phone calls, guys.
See, this basically reinforces my belief that never pick up phone calls, because if it's important enough, it'll go to voicemail.
Because, like, I'm also like, who calls me?
I don't give my number out to anybody.
So I was like, who the fuck is calling me?
And the people that do have my number would text me or message me on Discord.
I'm like, if you ever would've reached him... Honestly, I would most likely be more reachable on Discord than I would be on my phone.
Because I have... My phone is on silent mode, so it, like, you know, obviously it doesn't ring or anything.
So it vibrates whenever I get, like, you know, notifications.
But the thing is, because it, like, vibrates when it gets notifications, I won't hear it because I'm wearing my fucking headphones.
Even if my phone is near me, I won't be able to hear it.
So it's easier to reach out to me on Discord, because, like, I'm on my PC if I have my headphones on.
So I'm like... So people would most likely reach out to me on my... on Discord.
And the ones who have my phone number would just message me on Discord if they ever want to reach out to me.
So I was like, who the fuck is calling me?
Anyway...
Oh, yes!
Someone asked me my opinion on Dynasty Warriors Origins.
The only critique I have about the new Dynasty Warriors game is that I wish I get to play the actual characters more than my... the self-insert.
Because, like, not gonna lie, you know, it's great that I'm romancing other Chinese generals, but I would prefer to play as the generals and then romancing other generals.
I feel like... not gonna lie, I think I would be much more into it and much more, like, you know, I think I'm still into it.
But, like, I definitely would think it would be much more enjoyable if I was playing as one of the Chinese generals and then doing the same thing.
Because...
Anyway, I am reformed, though, by the way.
I am very much reformed.
Just imagine if I was playing, like, Guan Yun or something and I was talking to Lu Bu and it's the same dialogue.
I feel like it would be a lot more... it would be a lot more funnier, too.
It would be a lot more funnier, as well.
Yoshi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait, important question.
Can you romance Lian Shi?
Wait, who's Lian Shi again?
Who's Lian Shi?
Wait, I don't think I remember Lian Shi.
Wait, who's Lian...
Oh, for Lady Bu, one of Sun Quan's historical wives.
Oh, I don't remember Lian Shi.
Did they add... oh, she added her later.
I don't remember her that much.
To be fair, she's also in, like... she's also Sun Quan's wife.
And, like, I did not care much about Sun Quan.
I think it's because, like, Sun Quan...
Sun Quan, like, voice acting back in the older games was a little, like, ridiculous.
Like, he sounded like... okay, I remember Sun Quan's voice acting, but I could never take him serious.
Because he sounded, like, a little silly.
And he looks a little... he sometimes... like, his very first iteration was a little silly.
So, I could never...
I could never, like, get into Sun Quan in general.
So, like, I don't think I cared much about Lian Shi because of it.
Because he was... she was, like, part of his storyline.
So, like, that's why I don't remember... I don't remember Lian Shi at all.
I remember, like... oh my god, they gave Sun Shan Xian a fucking bow?!
When did they give her a bow?!
What the fu...
I don't remember... oh, wait, I remember.
No, never mind.
I remember her having a bow.
That shit was dumb.
I remember... that was such a... that was so weird when they...
I remember... sorry.
I remember playing the game where she had a bow and then I blocked it out of my memory.
Because I was like, not my Sun Shan... not my Sun Shan Xian.
That's not her.
She looked so... and then they changed her entire character design too.
Just for... just for that moment.
Anyway, sorry.
Game time.
It's gaming time.
Anyway...
Alright, sorry.
That was a 40 minute yapping session.
It's time... it's time to actually play the game, guys.
Alright.
Next scene.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I just feel like, you know...
I just think I'd be much more immersed if I'm actually playing as the... you know, the generals in the game.
Because like, you know, they were part of history.
I'm just a self-insert, guys.
It's just that.
That's all... that's basically not because I could like, you know...
Aw man, I'm so broke, guys.
Why did no one stop me?
Okay, no, that's fine.
I just sell my older weapons.
That's okay.
I might be broke, but I can sell my old other weapons and then be rich again, right guys?
Okay.
It's not even that much money, though.
That sucks.
It's not that much money.
Oh my god, all my fucking fists are weak as hell.
Okay, let's just sell all of these.
Wait, 91?
Which one am I using?
Wait, where am I equip... which one am I...
Okay, okay, it's this.
Okay, now 81.
Uh, let's sell all the weaker ones first.
And then...
Okay, nice.
Uh, 81...
85...
God, I'm so broke right now.
I spent it all on Lu Bu.
I spent all my money on Lu Bu, guys.
But Lu Bu was worth it.
It was so worth it, though.
It was so worth it.
Okay, let me hydrate real fast.
Uh, Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Danny, thank you for the super chat.
Reform, more like you got back into top.
Guys, I've reformed.
I swear to god.
I used to...
Guys, I was so bad.
I was...
Guys, I used to read fanfiction and, like, actively followed.
JP and Korean and Chinese artists.
That would drew artwork of my favorite ships, guys.
I was... And then, like, I would find their, like, secret websites.
Where they put the more...
The more...
The down baddest artwork.
Where they would put up secret websites of it.
And then you have to find the password that they've hidden in their fucking blog.
To access their secret website.
Because they don't want just anyone looking at their secret website.
They want the most down bad person to find...
The ones that can truly appreciate their favorite pairing.
Like, I don't know if they still do that.
But back in my day, when I was a Tumblr...
Back in my day, when I was a Tumblr girl.
A lot of artists, a lot of the JP Chinese or Korean artists.
They would have a separate website or blog.
Dedicated to where things go real, real after dark.
So...
And they post their more...
Their more crazier fanart.
So like, you have...
The thing is, you have to find the hidden password.
In their...
In their public...
In their public blog.
To access the after dark blog.
And I was that dedicated to access the after dark blog.
To satisfy my wants and needs for specific pairings.
So anyway, I'm reformed now.
I don't do that no more.
I'm very, very...
I'm very reformed now, guys.
Yes, my wants for these two...
My two favorite characters to do very bad things to each other.
But I'm reformed now.
It's not on my mind no more.
I don't have a favorite pairing.
I...
I don't have...
I don't do that no more, guys.
I don't do that.
Anyway, I'm too busy having a streaming career.
I told you guys what my favorite pairings were back then.
I told you.
Guys, okay, by the way...
Okay, I'll tell you this story.
When I was...
Sorry.
Okay, I'll tell you.
Okay, so like when I was first unpacking...
I've only bought two doujins in my entire life.
Because one of the...
And both...
One of them...
And I found they were not...
By the way, they were not safe for work.
I'll say...
They were...
They were absolutely not safe for work.
But I found one of...
I found one of them.
And like the only reason why I bought that doujin...
Was because it was a rare pair.
And like I was literally...
And okay...
Since we're playing Dynasty Warriors...
It was a Dynasty Warriors rare pairing.
So...
Like I needed as much content as I can to satisfy...
Like my...
My want to see artwork of those two.
So...
So I...
When one of my...
The...
One of the fucking five...
Three artists...
Good artists that draws them...
Like it was a JP artist.
And they were...
They were one of those...
I think it was like three.
They were one of three JP artists...
That I was able to find...
That fucking satisfy...
My itch to see those two characters...
Do stuff to each other.
So...
And it was very difficult...
Because it's like...
It was a rare pair.
So like...
There's barely any content.
I'll be like...
Please feed me.
I'm fucking dying.
I was like...
Please feed me.
I'm dying.
I'm starving.
I'm fucking starving.
And so...
The artist released a doujin.
And then I was like...
Oh my god.
I...
Thank you for feeding me.
Thank you.
And I fucking ordered that straight away.
And...
I was like...
Oh my god.
I'm sorry.
Thank you.
And so it was like...
My very first time...
I've ever owned...
Like a doujin before.
Because like...
Literally like...
It was such a rare pair.
That I was just like...
I need this.
I required sustenance.
And like...
I found it.
I was like...
Oh my god.
I found it.
And then I like...
Messaged one of my friends.
Because like...
Because I messaged one of my friends.
And then...
I was like...
I found something.
And he was like...
What?
And I was just like...
It's...
I took a picture of the inside of it.
And he was like...
Why did you send me that?
I was like...
I was just like...
It's my very first doujin.
When I was like...
A fujo.
I was like...
Not to cut the content.
Okay.
Guys.
I was a fujo.
I'm Kira now.
I'm reformed.
Check it out, bro.
I was like...
Bro, check it out.
This is what I used to be.
Okay, I won't tell you my rare pair, guys.
Guys, they're historical figures.
I can't.
I can't, guys.
They're historical.
They're actual real people.
I can't tell you who my rare pair was.
I can't.
You buy my silence, chat.
I can't do it for free.
I already gave so much info, guys.
You gotta buy my silence for this.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I found two doujins.
Ah, yes.
I also enjoyed Tao Tao's poems.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Anton.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The lady who screams and busts muff buff muscle men, flaring dinosaur warriors.
Don't protest too much.
Anton.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my funds are revealed.
The rare pair.
Go on and tell us.
Thank you for the super chat, PK.
Thank you.
Oh, no.
Please.
No.
Oh, my God.
Guys.
Okay.
This is, like, extreme rare pair.
I will admit, it was actually...
It was, like...
It's, like, really, really...
It's, like, extreme rare pair.
That's...
Oh, man.
Okay.
Oh, fuck.
It's a little...
It's a little embarrassing, guys.
Oh, my God.
It's a little...
It's a little embarrassing, guys.
It's...
Oh, man.
Okay.
It's...
I'm...
I'm trying to...
Oh, my God.
We're...
We're listening.
Okay, guys.
I just need you guys to know...
There was barely any content of it.
And, like, I...
I was, like...
I was...
I was dying.
Okay?
And, like, I needed someone to feed me.
And it was the rare moments where I can actually be fed.
Because, like...
There was barely anything...
Anything there at that time.
And I was, like, please.
Please feed me.
I just...
Please.
I just need just a little bit.
Just...
Just a little bit.
Okay.
So, my...
My rare pair was...
God, I'm so...
I talked about it before, too.
The thing is, I revealed this before.
But, like, now that I gave you more context of how fucking starved I was, it's a little embarrassing.
It was...
It was Juge Dan and Sima Zhao.
And...
That was the...
That was the doujin I owned.
And then, sometimes...
Sometimes, if I'm, like, desperate, I would be okay with Juge Dan and Sima Xi.
But, like, my main pair...
My...
My main pair was Juge Dan and Sima Zhao.
And, like...
Because, like, Juge Dan is, like, you know...
He's, like...
He's, like, the...
Yeah, Juge Dan and the Sima Zhao.
And I had...
And, look...
Look, I...
Like...
Look...
Okay, look.
You would understand if you know these characters.
You would understand.
Because, like...
Yeah, Dan is rim and proper.
And Zhao is a bad boy.
Yes, exactly.
You know what I'm talking about.
It's, like...
Yes, you know exactly what I'm talking about.
And, like, Juge Dan is, like, the strategist of the Jin Dynasty.
And, like, he's, like...
He's, like...
Oh, yeah.
Like, you're just, like...
And he's, like...
Like, you know, like...
Um...
The suck-up strategist that's trying to prove something.
And...
That ain't right.
That's just hate.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
But no one was making content of it.
It's rare because no one was making content.
Guys, I was so down bad for, like...
I was not used to having a rare pair fixation, guys.
Because in the past, all the pairings I liked had a lot of content.
But I was so desperate for anything.
I went to Pixiv and was, like...
I went to Pixiv.
That was how desperate I was.
I was, like, trying to find the tags for that specific pairing.
Because I was, like...
I need more content.
And I was trying to find the specific Japanese tag that pertains to that specific pairing, guys.
I needed more content.
I was not used to having a rare pair that I really liked.
I was not used to it.
Orca, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
Anyway, there you go.
I shared my shame, guys.
I...
Guys, I shared my shame today.
I'm reformed now.
I am a reformed Fujo.
I fixed myself, guys.
I'm not...
I'm not like that anymore, guys.
I swear to God, I have recovered.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh my God, thank you, Dragos, for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You achieved so much.
Has it all been for peace?
And the people used to carry out your duties as they came with no greater ambitions.
But now it seems as though you have a pair of wings ready to take whatever your heart desires.
Even a cage bird cannot help but yearn for flight after witnessing the sky beyond.
So where will you go next, Guardian of Peace?
What future do you foresee?
Oh my God, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my God, that felt like a natural super chat right... right there.
Alright, Yuan Shao.
Not joking, I didn't expect to see you at the battle, Yuan Shao.
And I've not heard a word from you since.
Have you nothing to say to me?
If you're too timid to call for a meeting, I'll have to give you the opportunity to break this silence myself.
If you do not come to me, you shall regret it.
Okay, we gotta meet Yuan Shao.
Oh my God, Zhang Yi.
This was one of my dad's favorite characters.
Please forgive me for this unsolicited letter.
I can only assume it must feel like an ambush of sorts.
Don't allow me to introduce myself.
Oh, do allow me to introduce myself.
I am Zhang Yi.
And at this moment, there is nothing in the world I would like more than to speak with you.
Would you be willing to grant me an audience if only this once?
I believe that we may have some degree of compatibility, but one never truly knows.
Until they tried.
If you would agree, then do look forward to my...
Oh my God, Zhang Yi.
Oh my God.
Okay.
Alright.
Wow.
Not so dead full.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I've heard less reforms and more relapsed.
Enjoy your brilliant man, queen.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Can't say it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
With one small donation, you too can feed a hungry Fujiyoshi in your area.
Call this toll-free number now.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Chill.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That is not...
I don't.
I swear to God, I do not, guys.
I have no favorite pairing in Marvel Rivals, guys.
I swear to God.
Guys, I didn't even have one in Apex.
All I cared about was the game, guys.
All I did was grind the game.
I've reformed, guys.
Ever since I got into gaming, guys.
Ever since I got into rank and gaming and streaming.
I don't do that no more, guys.
I swear.
I've reformed.
I'm too busy.
Bro.
Trust me, bro.
Bro, I'm one of you.
Bro.
Bros, guys.
I'm too busy gaming, bro.
Trust me.
Affiliate.
I can't believe you pulled a bone card, bro.
Affiliate, thank you for the five kisses.
Thank you.
I swear, bro.
It's different now.
I swear.
Wait, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm a Fudanshi.
I feel your pain.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, shit.
Damn, wait.
What's this?
Yeah, but he wants to see me.
Oh, wait.
I forgot to be Left Side Doki.
Alright, goodbye Right Side Doki.
You shall cease to exist now.
Alright, where's Left Side Doki?
Where did I put Left Side Doki?
There you are.
Left Side Doki is different, guys.
Left Side Doki is even more reformed.
Aww, he adopted him.
That's me.
I'm special.
I'm Cao Cao's favorite special guest.
I'm more reformed, by the way.
I'm the more reformed Doki.
What did Left Side Doki and Right Side Doki kiss?
Alright, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait, they're still around?
Yeah, they're for...
Yeah, exactly.
Bro, in the other...
I mean, they are remnants of them in actual history.
But in the other Dynasty Warriors, when you kill them, they're just gone.
They never existed.
Yeah, I killed him.
They don't know that.
He literally looks like Lu Bu's younger brother.
He's like 30.
He's like almost the same age as Sun Jian.
Our lord was appointed to the post because the former governor, Liu Dai, was murdered by these yellow turbans from Qing.
It has benefited us to have this territory as a base, but we cannot govern properly while such a threat lingers.
Right.
And if those rebels were to launch a full-on invasion, the whole province would be devastated.
We have heard reports that they don't even bring their own supplies.
What the fuck?
That's so risky.
How the fuck would you rely on stealing?
You know you're immune to steal stuff.
Do not think of them as mere rabble.
They're an enemy willing to do anything.
Treat them as such.
They're unlike the yellow turbans we fought before.
So keep your guard up.
Remember... what was her name?
The flute girl?
Sorry.
Tao Pei's wife.
And she was like, man, you're so lucky.
I wish I can be like... I wish I can be... I can experience the outside world and there's literally like poverty and death.
And I was like, do you really?
Chen Ji, yeah.
I was like...
I was like, was it Chen Ji?
I can't... I couldn't fully remember.
I was like not that sure of myself.
And she was like, I wish I could be just like you.
And I was like, do you... Oh my god, you're so... you're so sheltered.
There's literally people eating each other right now.
Alright, Yuan Shao, what do you want to talk about?
What do you want, Yuan Shao?
That's me!
By chance?
I'm healthy!
And reformed.
I'm just a mercenary for hire.
Like a true great...
Such truthful words.
Nobles are truly so great.
Blurgo, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Dude, I gotta say... Doki, I gotta say thank you and curse you thrice over.
I'm now dignant once more in the battle for Middle-Earth.
Wait, he prepared feast for me?
Oh my god!
Oh, he's definitely courting me.
Oh my god, a feast?
I think he's into me, guys.
That's right.
Throw money at the problem, it always works.
Well, I mean, for me it does.
It actually always works.
Whoa!
Bro!
Not Doki, you're wild!
I wish you were...
Whoa!
Yeah.
Damn!
Hi, problem.
Gavin, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, so it's after the food, though?
Oh yeah, chow.
Oh, look at the way he looks at me!
Oh my god!
Bro, what happens after the food?
Bro, that fucking stare!
That glance right after!
Guys, I'm rooting for him, I swear.
The feast with you was entertaining to say the least.
As a reward, I shall bestow you with this.
Oh, he just makes me do more stuff?
Okay.
I'm reformed, guys.
I swear to god, I am better now.
Okay, I'm 23.
Okay.
Oh, I get to have an accessory!
Guys, all we had was dinner, guys.
That's it.
Nothing else happened, guys.
We just had dinner, okay?
He gave me a gift after, but like, it doesn't mean anything, guys.
He gave me a gift right after dinner, but it meant nothing.
Okay, let's see.
Gong Ning battle with using the short 100 with using a battle spear.
With charge attack.
Okay, I just need to do a charge attack.
I was wondering if I need, like... I remember I had, like, accessories.
Oh yeah, okay.
That's fine.
Alright, let's kill these guys first.
Okay.
Yeah, I needed to kill these guys first.
Nice.
Oh my god, I hate using every... I hate using stuff that's not... that's not the spin... what's it called?
The spinny wheels one?
Enemy forces are firing a volley of archers from high ground?
Where's the high ground?
Oh wait, guys, where's the high ground?
I don't know where the high ground is.
Jesus Christ, there's so many people here.
Where's the high ground?
Oh my god, oh no.
Guys, I think my entire... I think they're all gonna die.
Okay, that's fine.
Everything will be fine.
I just need to kill him.
Okay, nice counter.
But where is it?
Where the fuck is the high ground?
Oh no.
Wait, there's more than two?
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
I can... I can fight two.
Jesus Christ, there's so many people.
There's so many people.
Where are they?
Okay, that's fine.
Counter.
There we go.
My little man.
I'm here for... Oh wait, no, I'm the little man.
I'm here for the short kings.
Oh shit.
Oh fuck, oh fuck, oh fuck!
I was too far!
It's okay.
It's fine.
Got him.
Nice.
Where's the other guy?
Wait, where's the other guy?
There was another guy that I almost killed.
Okay, I don't know where he is.
No, no, not the reinforcements.
No, no.
I just killed one!
What do you mean there's a reinforcement?
Jesus, I'm doing nothing to him!
Okay, nice.
Oh my god.
Bro, they're doing no damage!
Oh wait, my allies have reached high ground.
That's good.
Okay.
Bye.
Oh my god.
Why am I doing no damage?
I do not have enough allies.
Oh shit.
Oh fuck!
Let go!
No!
He got it!
He has so much energy now!
My guard has fled?!
When you left me?!
Dragoons, why did you leave me?!
What do you mean?!
Oh my god, I'm still fighting this one guy.
I will be there, I swear to god.
I swear to god, I will be there soon.
I have to deal with this right now.
Oh my god, this fight is taking forever.
This one guy is taking fucking forever.
What?!
Oh my god, what the fuck?
It's fine.
He's dead.
Okay, we gotta help this other guy.
Oh my god, where's the other guy that I have to help?
He's like right here.
I have no bread though.
Don't worry, eat your bread!
Eat your bread!
It's fine, he ate his bread!
I'm so happy he ate his bread!
It's fine.
Okay, this guy was so fast.
Oh fuck, okay.
It's okay.
He can't be as difficult as that last guy I fought.
Alright.
Nice.
Alright, nice.
Okay.
Just gotta break one more.
Guys, I killed Wu Bu.
This is easy for me.
I need to find bread though soon.
I need a lot of bread.
Oh fuck, I forgot to block in.
Get over here, send me!
You're a default model!
I refuse to die to a default!
Okay.
Break his shield.
I just need one more shield break.
Oh fuck!
No, I refuse to die to a default!
Nice.
Alright.
We did it.
See that bread?
He has bread.
Okay, we gotta go grab some bread at a nearby house real fast.
Okay, let's grab.
Let's get bread here.
Don't die!
I refuse.
I refuse to die by a fucking default.
Oh, there it is.
There's the bread.
How did my spear not hit the one thing in front of me?
Okay, nice.
We have two.
We have extra bread.
Alright, raid the village guys.
I like how...
I was like, how could they raid a fucking village for food when they could just get supplies?
Guys, I'm part of the problem.
I raided that village too.
There's a guy.
There's a general right here.
Nice.
Get over there.
We gotta help out.
That's fucking right.
Get counted.
Oh, you don't have a name so I know you'd be easy.
That's right.
Get out of here.
You don't matter.
You matter even less because you have no name.
And then we gotta take this base.
Alright, get over here.
Open it.
Open the base!
Doki is coming in!
Get in here!
Okay, nice.
Is there anyone guarding it?
Like actual people guarding it?
Oh, nice.
More bread for me.
You ain't stealing your supplies.
I'm not a thief, guys.
I'm just taking my taxes.
They're just my tax payments, guys.
I'm a tax collector.
Oh, shit.
No!
I didn't mean to use my bar up!
Oh, wait.
I didn't.
Okay.
Thank God.
I thought I accidentally used my musou.
I'm not a thief, guys.
I'm just taking what I was owed.
That's different.
Get over here.
Come on, challenge me!
Challenge me!
Please, it's easier if you challenge me!
Nice.
Oh, fuck.
I missed it.
It's fine.
I'm okay.
So, where's your shout?
Wait, where the fuck did he come from?
Wait!
Wait up!
Fuck!
He just was like...
Peekaboo!
I was like...
Wait, where the fuck did he come from?
He literally just appeared in front of him.
Nice.
Wait, I wanna...
I don't wanna target him.
I wanna...
There you go.
Nice counter.
I was like, where did you come from?
Nice.
I get to have a 2 for 1 special.
No!
Oh, wait.
No, he's still here.
That's what you are.
Get over here.
Wait, I can kill him right now.
Let me just kill him just for XP.
I need you for XP, buddy.
There we go.
Oh, fuck.
Not...
Not there you go.
Give me your XP!
Nice!
Wait, where's your Inshall?
I like fucking chucked him all the way there?
What the fuck?
I was like, where did he go?
I like how I just randomly chucked him all the way to the other side.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, shit!
Can't dodge that.
Can't ever keep forgetting you can't dodge that.
Okay, nice.
I broke his other armor piece.
Please.
Die!
I like how I just talked to him just to kill him again.
He bought me dinner and then I was like, alright, time to kill you.
Okay.
Nice.
One more.
Just one more kill.
One more stab.
Woo!
Goodbye.
Nice!
Yay!
I did it!
Thanks for the dinner, Inshall.
I really appreciate it.
Thanks for the free meal.
I'll kill you now.
Nice.
Alright.
Skill points.
Did I do it?
Oh, I didn't do 500.
Fuck!
Okay, I need five.
I need...
I need a few more left.
And then what about my other training?
62.
I only did 62 with that?
Oh, no.
I definitely forgot about the charge attack, though.
I forgot to use...
I forgot my spear has a charge attack.
I was definitely not charging.
I felt like I was like...
I felt like I was killing so many people!
Nice.
Sorry about that, buddy.
Hey, thanks for the...
Thanks for the free food.
I really appreciate it.
Hey, peace has risen!
Whoa, I brought more peace!
No need to thank me.
I'm a hero.
Okay, let's see.
Where do I go?
Oh, I have someone to talk to.
Who's he?
Wait, who are you?
Oh, is this Zhang Yi?
Oh, Zero.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
We all know.
Not too cute.
No!
Oh my God, my turn.
Wait, he's less?
Wait, his voice actor is less?
Wait, that's not the Zhang Yi I know.
Wait, what happened to him?
What happened to him?
He's less flamboyant.
What happened?
Why is he less fabulous?
Zhang Yi!
What did they do to you?
Zhang Yi, no!
You used to be so fabulous!
Talk about what?
I literally massacred my boy.
Trust me, I'm listening.
What did they do to you, my boy?
Yes, he's the claw guy!
He's the flamboyant, fabulous guy!
Oh my gosh.
Wait, maybe I'm like...
Is it crazy to say that I'm taking him out of the closet right now?
Is that crazy for me to say?
I'm the first.
Zhang Yi.
Your ideal?
I'm the gate awakening!
I'm not even in the service of Liu Bei.
You were merely a guest of theirs.
The revelation was such a shock that I was forced to reflect on my own life.
You stand on the battlefield of your own volition.
You give me too much credit.
No, it is you who underestimates your own value.
I believe that all paths in my life will lead me to the field of battle.
For it is there that I can express my ability to its fullest potential.
Snatching victory from the jaws of a brutal struggle.
It is when I'm close to death that I feel the certainty of why.
I have no hesitation in this way of life.
However, I had never considered the choice of not following someone else.
Oh, how narrow-minded I have been.
I don't think I can go on fighting much longer.
Now that I know.
Is that what you think?
You don't sound...
Oh, fascinating what you do.
If you don't have no objections, I would like to get to know you better.
Hmm.
Let us spend the night discussing philosophies on...
The fuck does that even mean?
What the fuck does that even mean?
Oh my god.
Okay, for those who don't know what he used to sound like.
Okay, I'll show you guys.
Jung Hee... Okay.
Fab.
Okay, let's see.
Let's see if I can...
Let's see if I can find some of my favorite voice acting from this.
Alright.
Okay.
Oh, sorry.
I didn't realize I muted myself.
Oh my god.
Oh man, but I actually muted the round.
I was trying to mute the game.
But like...
It was so...
No, I accidentally muted my game.
I muted myself.
I was trying to mute my game.
But like...
That was what he sounded like.
He was so fabulous.
And okay, but then in Dynasty Warriors 5...
They made a cutscene where he was just dancing with his...
With his army.
And you're like...
Wait, why is he doing that?
It was so...
It was so random.
It was... He was just doing a fucking...
Dance.
Yeah, I muted my game on purpose so you guys can like hear it.
And they like...
They like...
He like danced with his army.
And it was like...
And you're like...
Why?
But that's like...
It was my favorite.
It was my dad's favorite.
And I loved...
I loved the character too.
Like the style points.
I wonder if Dynasty Warriors 9...
If he was like...
He was still like that.
Let me see.
Okay, I'm trying to see his like voice acting in Dynasty Warriors 9.
Oh my gosh.
Was he still the same in Dynasty Warriors 9?
I wish I could be this fabulous.
I don't remember.
Let's see.
Where is it?
Where is his character?
Where is his like voice acting?
Okay, the Zhang He ending.
Does he still sound like that or no?
Is he still fabulous?
Oh, even in Japanese!
Even in Japanese, he was like...
Oh my god, the music is louder than him though.
Are you seeing this?
He's also...
Oh my god.
He sounds great.
Oh, it was Dynasty Warriors 9, not in English?
Alright, maybe in...
Oh my god, but yes.
Back then, he was...
He used to...
That's why I was like...
Why did they...
What did they do to you?
Zhang He.
Why are you so normal now?
I don't like it.
I was like...
No!
Why are you so normal?
But yeah, you guys wanna hear more about what he sounded like?
This is what he sounded like.
I was like...
No!
My beautiful peacock man!
All he wanted to do was dance!
Oh, here's more.
All he cared about was his beauty!
What did they do to you?
Oh my god, I'm so sad!
You just wanted to show the world your beauty!
I believe everyone has some beauty within them.
But your beauty, general, will be quite difficult to divine.
Why do you keep staring at me?
I don't know.
I'm gonna stare.
Do it now.
Dance!
That feeling when you miss someone you haven't even met.
He just wanted to beautify the world!
How could they do this to you?
How could they?
How would you make the world beautiful?
It's a prequel!
Don't worry, I'll bring it back!
I found that time spent with you is never wasted.
I think we can be honest with one another, even if we end up on opposite sides of the battlefield.
We both find life's meaning in battle.
I'm glad to have met you.
You're not the same.
You're not as beautiful as before they took your light.
They took away your light.
What if we awaken?
What if he hasn't awakened to beauty yet?
Oh my god, you're right!
You're right!
Oh my god, you're so right!
He just hasn't found it yet.
I shall awaken the beauty inside him, guys.
I shall be his beauty awakening.
Candid, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's extra funny because historical Zhang Yi was a puff-bearded badass and one of the most OP...
Okay, that's pretty funny.
Where the fuck did Dynasty Warriors' Zhang Yi come from then?
Oh my god.
Like, how is that... where did that come from?
Okay, so you guys said I can do like...
Wait, what does it say?
Recommend battle level?
I am not there yet.
You guys said I could technically do the other ones.
It doesn't matter.
So like, I'm gonna do the other battles then.
His inner beauty is gonna come out, right guys?
That's right.
Oh wait, I didn't unlock this.
Oh my god, there's some...
He just made it!
They just...
Thank you for the superchat, thank you, thank you.
They just... they're just like, you know what?
We need someone flamboyant in our game.
Let's just rewrite history.
Source myself.
It was just a really good design, guys.
They didn't want to waste it.
They just assigned a random design to it, guys.
It was just such a good design.
It would be careless to waste such an opportunity.
I wanna do a...
Wei or Wu mission.
That's absolutely... that's so funny.
They just made it up!
That's so fucking funny.
Oh shit, it's level 14?
Let's fucking do this one.
Oh wait, Zhang He's name in Japanese is Butterfly, so they're like...
Imagine like... like... 200 years in the future, your name is like...
You're just like... your name is just... reminds me of a butterfly.
So funny.
Historical inaccuracy in my...
Like, you were like one of the best generals in your land, and you're like...
I wonder what will history say about me.
Like...
Imagine that.
They're just like, man...
I hope... I hope my... I hope my descendants talk about the amount of...
The amount of things I've done for my country.
And then they turned you into a flamboyant...
Flamboyant...
This is your entire personality now.
That's abs... that's crazy.
That's so funny.
Alright, nice.
Okay, finish one of the objectives.
What did I finish?
I did the 500 foes.
And then...
Spear training.
Which one do I mean?
Okay, using... Okay, I just didn't use battle arts.
There we go.
This is your legacy now.
That's abs...
This is your legacy now!
Oh my god!
That's crazy.
That's your legacy.
Like, Lu Bu...
Lu Bu gets like a whole fucking arc about him.
I mean...
Deserved, really, because he was like one of the strongest men in ancient China.
And then Zhang He, who was like a great general for his faction.
And like was buffed and trained every day and killed so many people.
And then the developers were like...
Your name sounds like a butterfly.
It was like, let's make up your story.
Poor guy.
I like that.
To be fair, I like that version of Zhang He.
I like the dynasty warriors, Zhang He.
I'm sorry.
Nice.
Easy.
I'll just take this base real quick.
You know what?
You can fire some arrows.
Silly, silly guys.
Alright, nice.
Oh, wait.
It was just that easy.
Nice.
How much more do I have to do for this one?
Oh, I just need ten more.
Alright, nice.
Beauty is strength.
This is why you keep it in your will.
In your will, just right in there.
Do not make up character traits.
If I ever get put in a dynasty warriors game, please don't make up my story.
Okay, nice.
I finished it.
Nice.
Easy.
And we have two more bases left.
Alright.
Okay, we finished that.
You know what?
Let's...
We don't need to do Lu Bu stuff because we technically...
We technically finished all of his because we did pay to win.
So, I guess we can...
We can do...
Yeah,
we maxed out Lu Bu.
I'm pretty sure.
You know damn well I'm not doing it for the skill points.
Guys, you know damn well we are not doing this for the skill points.
We're doing it for something more important than that.
Okay, we'll use the Twin Peaks.
Oh wait, can I not change it?
I should be able to change it now.
I stopped.
Okay, I should have a... 89.
There you go.
Nice.
Alright.
Let's go grab the other base.
It is absolutely not for the skill points.
Okay.
Nice.
Yeah, you think you can do anything?
Oh my god, I hope he fucking eats some bread real quick.
Jesus, this weapon is so slow though.
I'm not a fan of how slow this weapon is.
Jesus, why are you running?
Why the fuck are you running?
Hey, you started this fight.
You fucking started this fight, buddy.
Yeah, this is my area.
Oh, we won.
I did it.
The AI won the game for me.
Let's go.
Yay!
I don't know if I like the Twin Peaks.
It's such a slow weapon.
Which one's the best one so far?
Is it still the wheels?
Is the wheels still the best weapon in this game?
It feels like it.
Okay, nice.
Unlock new skill panel.
Yay, birch!
You're stronger now!
Okay, the wheels.
Okay, I like the wheels the most.
Nice.
I got two sphere trainings.
I got that.
97 skill points.
Yay!
Okay, let's upgrade.
Let's just do it by... I'm just gonna do it by the order.
Oh, I haven't unlocked ultimate battle arts?
Okay, and then... Oh wait, there we go.
I wanted to do...
I wanted to do theirs because we can't do all of them for now.
Sun Jian's headquarters.
Oh, sorry.
I accidentally interrupted him.
Shall you say?
I was definitely not there a moment ago.
I know he's still alive!
It's crazy!
This is the longest I've ever seen him alive in any Dynasty Warriors game.
By the time you play as him to stop your death.
Of course!
I haven't seen any of his sons yet.
None of his sons are still around.
Where is your bad mission?
Who the fuck is this mission?
Is it back here?
No, that's the new base thing, right?
No, that's the shop.
Nevermind.
That's the shop.
I'm so broke.
I have no money.
Oh, there's a fisherman.
Wait, I can't cross it.
No!
I wanna talk to the fisherman.
Where the fuck is the battle?
I'm so lost.
Nanyang, Yu province.
Was it this one?
I don't remember.
I don't remember, guys.
Was it this?
Oh my god, I'm so lost in all the battles.
Is it this one?
Oh yeah, I saw Nanyang.
There it is.
Sun Jian's forces.
There we go.
Hello, Sun Jian.
Can I fill up all the bubbles?
Can I still do all the bubbles for everybody?
Or is it like I just do it not until the last?
Okay, I can fill up all of them.
Okay.
Fair enough.
I just gotta go in a straight path.
Leave it to me.
Alright, Huang Gai.
Okay, we'll get Huang Gai in here.
It's not the same.
The thing I don't like about Sun Jian's army is that they don't really have a lot of generals that I like for me.
Like, I hate all his sons.
Okay, hate is a strong word.
But I'm not a fan of any of his sons.
And the only one I like is...
I love his... okay.
You're his one fan.
You're literally his one fan.
But for me, the only person I like in his army, his generals, is Sun Xianxian and Gan Ning.
That's the only ones I like in his army.
For his generals.
And Sun Jian.
But then they killed him off.
Not even Zhou Yu.
There's so many Zhou Yu's in all the other factions.
Like, have a Zhou Yu.
Guys.
They all have a Zhou Yu.
It was not that special.
Okay,
we can kill him fast.
Wei has exactly... Wei has like 8 Zhou Yu's if you think about it.
Oh shit, that's not what I wanted to do.
There we go.
If you think about it, Shu had like 10 of Zhou Yu.
That's what I'm saying.
The only ones I like was Gan Ning and Sun Xianxian.
That was the only one I like.
Like, we literally have like Zhao Yun and Shu, which is practically a Zhou Yu.
Okay, nice.
Oh, what the fuck?
Not nice.
True.
Get out of here.
Alright, open the door!
Open the door!
Am I breaking the door myself?
No, I'm waiting.
I was like, am I doing it?
You're right.
The best part were their wives and I didn't even remember.
But the thing is, I didn't even remember the wives.
The best part?
The best part of Sun Xian's forces were the women.
You're right.
No, absolutely.
The women that weren't actually like... like the two girls.
Wait.
Yeah, they were the women in there.
Yeah.
No, you're right.
Absolutely.
Alright, let's go.
Conquer another base.
Oh shit, what the fuck?
Do you know who I am?
Get out of here.
Get out of here!
Okay, nice.
I completed new boost training.
Get out!
Okay, let's get him out of here.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Alright, guards!
DRAGONS!
SHOOT THAT ARROW!
That's fucking right, get out!
Easy.
GO DRAGONS!
FOR DOKI!
Wait, there's one more.
What the fuck?
Where did he come from?
I was like, where did you come from?
Jesus, okay.
It's not fair that he could interrupt that.
I'm like, hello?
I am trying to shoot my thing.
Hello, open the door.
Oh yeah!
Yeah!
Alright, nice.
Get out of here.
That's right.
You think you can interrupt my attack?
Get out of here!
Yeah!
Okay, nice.
My proficiency has increased.
I didn't need to do that, but I just did it just for fun.
Wait, is there a general in here?
Oh, there is!
I was like, why is this taking so long?
There is a general here.
Okay.
That's fine.
There we go.
General's dead.
Alright, let's leave.
We did it, let's leave.
Open the gates!
Wait, there's more reinforcements?
That's fine.
You'll be fine.
And how do I...
Okay, jump up.
Wait, they can just do that?
What?
That's fine.
I can do this.
There we go.
What's going on?
Oh, I did this before the cutscene.
Oh shit, is this where he dies?
Guys!
Wait, where's me?
I was just there!
I literally made the first opening!
Oh shit, his son!
Wait, he uses his fists now?
Wait, what happened to...
Wait, what happened to his other weapon?
The sticks!
The tonfa!
Bro became a fister.
Wait, is he gonna punch the arrow?
Oh, it's the other son!
No, it's Zhou Yu!
Wait, what the fuck?
He's using the staff?
Oh, it's him.
Wait, when did he used to be a sword user?
Wait, did he have a staff since 7?
I liked him when he... I forgot about that.
I personally liked his sword better.
Guys, she hasn't finished...
No, she's like... what is she in like historically wise?
I forgot.
She should not be in war right now.
What I do know is that she should not be in battle right now.
Okay.
Nice.
Nice, Sun Jian!
Extreme by Pio when the swap gauges are out?
Okay.
Wait, what are they doing here?
Why are they behind me?
You guys are idiots.
Okay, nice.
Alright, we got it.
Get through the gates!
Let's go!
Let's use it on these guys!
Oh my god.
Oh my...
Woah!
He's still 9, Doki.
That hasn't changed.
Doki, that has not changed.
She's still 9.
What is she doing in the battlefield?
Get out of here, Sun Jian!
Okay.
Nice.
Oh my god, he's so strong.
Bro, that's cheating.
Oh my god, I did not see my HP.
I did not realize how low I was.
Nice counter.
Get out.
Come on.
Let me fight you!
Okay, nice.
Get out!
Oh my god, you're too spongy.
The only thing I... Also, another critique is that so many of the generals are so spongy now.
Let's go.
Alright, let's go.
We gotta move forward.
We gotta go this way.
Alright, open the door!
Let's go!
Yeah, but I feel like they're way too spongy.
I think if they toned down the sponginess, I think it would be better.
Some of them are like... I don't think default man should be that spongy.
You know?
Spin!
Okay.
What?
Alright, that's it.
I'm angry.
DRAGONS, GO!
Like, if you don't have a skin, you should be faster to kill.
Nice.
My base now.
Alright, open the door!
Let's go.
Guys, this is actually crazy.
This is like the most...
The most, like, we've ever progressed in the game.
The last three games, guys.
The last three parts.
If you think about it, this is actually the most we've ever progressed in the...
We actually are doing two... We did like three fights, guys.
It's crazy.
Wait, no, this is our fourth fight!
Oh my god.
We're doing it, guys.
We're actually progressing the story.
Open the door.
Open the door!
Wait, am I supposed to be back there?
No, I don't think so.
No way.
Okay, nice.
That's right.
Interrupt.
Get out of here!
That's fucking right!
I'm him!
Is there another boss?
No.
Okay, my base now.
Alright, let's see if there's any objectives.
Okay, complete a Lu Bu's objective.
Using Musou attacks.
Launch a successful...
Where's the other one with... Wait, where's the other one with the Twin Peaks?
Finish a combo with Enhance.
Okay, I was not doing that.
Wait, I did none of that?
Wait, what?
Okay.
Clearly, I was not doing my objective, guys.
Whoops.
Oops.
I thought I was!
Okay, I just need to press Y.
Just press Y.
I can do that.
Okay.
Get the pause in Strong Cat when the pikes light up?
I have to pause?
Oh my- I'm just gonna pay.
Fuck it, I'm just gonna pay.
Oh, you think- What the fuck?!
How do I- Okay.
Wait.
You can't shoot me from here.
That's fine.
Rude Force, baby!
Rude Force!
That's fucking right!
Yes!
That's right!
Rude Force is the way to go.
That's fucking right!
I love Rude Forcing things!
Eventually, it'll work!
Nice, we did it.
Tactical genius!
I was like, wait, what do I do?
Oh, I'll just keep going forward.
It'll work eventually, right?
Right?
Nice.
See, guys?
Eventually, it'll work.
Oh, nice.
Alright.
Alright, Dracoons.
FIRE ARROWS!
That's fucking right, get counted!
I'm gonna do this thing!
Oh, nice, he's dead.
Oh, wait, no, he's not.
Okay, I need to get closer to him.
There we go.
Oh, thank you for the raid!
Thank you, thank you!
I didn't see who raided, but thank you so much!
That's fucking right.
Get twirled on!
Okay, I'll use my- wait, I can change characters, but I'm gonna use it later.
I'm gonna use it at the final boss.
There we go.
Okay, nice.
Get outta here.
That's right!
This is the final piece!
Nice, we did it!
Our base now!
Wait, was he a real person?
He was so easy.
There's no way.
He has to be a default man, right?
Oh, okay.
We did it.
Now is our time to shine!
Ready!
Charge!
Are we charging?
Oh, shit!
Wait, what?
The assault was successful?
What did I do?
Oh, fuck!
Wait, how is this successful?
I just got shot down from my fucking horse!
I was like, what do you mean successful?
I did something.
Alright, let's go.
Alright, it's time.
I'm ready!
I'm ready to start punch- why are you running?
Why are you running?
You're wasting my fucking meter!
Why the fuck are you running?
There we go.
What am I doing?
Oh, shit!
Oh my god, the fuck he made?
Defeat three enemy officers?
Wait, I just defeated one!
Wait, that's not fair!
What the fuck?
That's fucking right.
I'm ready.
I'm gonna start punching this.
Oh, fuck!
Oh, shit!
What the fuck happened?
Wait, I killed a general?
Oh my god.
I just killed- alright, get down from here.
Get down from here.
Like, I just randomly killed a general.
I don't even know how that happened!
I was like, what happened?
Wait, he's dead?
That's right, swing.
Swing time.
Where do I find another general?
General!
Okay, he's like right there.
Give me a sec, I'm heading over!
This dork, he was just that guy, Dirky.
Okay, there we go.
They were so far away from me that I caught him.
Okay, nice.
Get out of here.
I need one more general to die.
Get out!
Oh, shit.
Oh, shit!
Please, I just need one more!
Please!
Press?
There.
Please, I just need one more!
Nice, I got it.
We did it.
That's right, no more shield for you.
Oh, wow, oh my god, Hong Dang, how?
How, Hong Dang?
We literally killed everybody!
Stop being so pathetic!
That's, alright, I'll go straight.
Oh my god, his shield.
Where are we?
Oh my god, I do not have it.
Oh, there's so many people.
Oh, please don't crash.
Please don't crash.
Every time.
Oh, please don't crash.
Please don't crash.
Every time I hit a thousand, I get scared!
Oh, I'm a true warrior!
Oh, thank god, I'm a true warrior!
Oh, Suda-chan, please live.
Okay, nice.
Please don't.
I just want to be a true warrior!
Okay, nice.
Wait, who challenged me?
Who is it?
Who wants to battle me?
I can't see!
There's too many people who wants to battle me!
I can't tell!
There's too many!
I can't see!
Oh my god, where's Sifu?
Wait, okay, let me kill this Yiji first, and then I'll go get Sifu, whoever he is.
Okay, I swear to god!
Oh shit!
Oh shit, wait, I might actually die!
Wait a minute.
Oh, JKF.
Killing him got me food.
Where the fuck is he over here?
I can't move!
Where is he?
Oh my god, there you are!
I was like, where are they?
Okay, I got him.
It's fine.
I found him.
Guys, I found him.
I couldn't... there was too many people!
Like, did you see that?
I was like, what was I supposed to do?
Okay, nice.
Oh please, I need to kill him then.
Oh no, please, I went forward!
Where is he?
Oh my god, that guy!
Twist 20!
I did it!
Okay, nice.
We did it.
Okay, we made it, guys.
We fucking made it!
Okay, I just need to get rid of these guys.
Get rid of these guys too.
There's so many people.
Oh my god!
Wait, what do you mean they're closing in?
Fuck, try my best!
There's so many!
Okay, nice.
Don't worry, I'll protect him.
Wait, time limit?
Time remaining?
Okay, 14 minutes, that's fine.
That's fine.
We can make it.
Oh shit.
We can make it, guys!
Okay, that's it.
I'm done.
I'm done using this.
I'm bringing the big boys.
I'm bringing the big boys!
I'm fucking done playing around!
Oh shit.
Oh shit, okay.
Okay, okay, okay, guys.
Guys, calm down.
Guys, calm down!
Nice.
Okay, now he's dead.
Get out!
Get out of here!
Oh fuck!
Jesus Christ.
Do your thing!
Do your thing while I fight him in the background!
Wait, I'm still fighting him while this whole thing is going on.
I don't even see it!
Okay.
Oh my god, there's so many people that's in front of me.
I can't tell what's going on anymore.
There's too many people fighting.
Oh thank god, I got buns.
Oh shit!
Extreme Musou!
Nice.
Get over here.
Get over here, Lu Biao!
Get over here!
Oh shit, did I do it?
Oh nice, I did.
Okay, thank god.
I thought he was going to fucking kill me.
That's fucking right.
The big boys are here.
That's right.
I actually know how to use this weapon!
Oh fuck!
Oh, did I dodge it?
Oh, that was so close!
Oh my god, I dodged it again!
Okay, that scared me.
She died for this.
She died for all her sins.
We did it!
Guys, look at that, I actually dodged.
Perfect dodge.
Fun!
We did it, and he lives!
Alright, Twin Peaks.
Okay, we don't care about that.
Most historically accurate battle.
Oh nice!
Picked up a lot of weapons that I'm not going to use.
We got Lu Bu's thing.
We got another Lu Bu thing.
We got the Twin Peaks there.
Wow!
It lacks so much.
Alright, and that did a perfect thing.
Is there another Twin Peaks thing I have to do?
Let's see, defeat 50 enemies using pull it out.
I don't know this one.
I don't know how to do this one.
I'm just going to pay to win that.
I can't be bothered to figure this one out.
Oh, get defense here.
I mean, we can get all of them.
He's going to be so proud of me, guys.
Oh my god, he's going to be so proud of me.
It's a timing base?
Yeah, we're not going to get that right.
I just learned how to dodge.
I don't think I can learn the second thing.
Yeah, don't worry your boyfriend.
Sorry, your roommate.
Sorry, your roommate, guys.
That was me.
I did that.
Yeah.
Whoa, wait, wait.
Yeah, childhood friend, guys.
Oh, likewise.
This was not a rare pair, guys.
Fuck them for not being a rare pair.
Yeah, dad.
Where are you hiding from him?
Why is Student Quad not here yet?
Student Quad, like, inherits the throne.
Where the fuck is Student Quad?
Like...
He's like, all my sons are... all my children are here.
Oh, there he is!
Why the fuck was he not talking?
What the fuck?
Where did he come from?
He's right there.
Oh my god, he's so young!
Holy shit, who is he?
Why does he look like that?
He's so young!
He's eight.
Oh, guys.
If we can send Sun Quan Xian as a child soldier, we can send Sun Quan in.
She's only two years younger than her.
The Imperial Seal.
Then Liu Biao's attempt to prevent our return was...
Precisely.
My first thought was that they were coming after the seal.
But I have no intention of ever handing it over to the likes of them.
As a loyal subject of the Han, I will fulfill my duty to guard it with my life.
And when the time comes, I'll return it to His Majesty.
After discussing it with Cheng Pu, we have decided that this is the best path to take.
But, this also means that all of you will be dragged into the inevitable conflict that will arise.
As part of the family, just sail into the ocean.
Nobody can hurt you there.
If this is the path you've chosen for us, then we will be with you to the very end of it.
Won't we?
It's not like anything bad is going to happen to the family, guys.
The Red Mafia invites you to their family.
The most dangerous threat is the formal leader of the Alliance, Yuan Shao.
He believes that the Imperial seal belongs in his hands.
There are many other forces interested in claiming the seal for themselves.
It's like the family and also Sun Ce's boyfriend.
Sorry, Sun Ce's roommate.
I like how Joey is just there.
He's like, hey guys.
This is a family meeting and I'm family now.
Okay, I need to use the bathroom.
I'll be right back.
Still getting more water.
I'm back.
I'm back, everybody.
Allen, Medi, Byte, Poro, Krish, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
You think he's up to something?
This is most likely a trap meant to trick us into destroying each other.
And then he'll pick at our remains like some kind of vulture.
Yuan Shao is a treacherous fool.
He is indeed.
But I plan to jump right into this trap of his all the same.
To protect the Imperial seal from the chaos of our world, we must be prepared to ally with beasts.
See, Zhou, you should be standing there.
Like where all the non-family members are.
Why the fuck is he in the family meeting?
Guys,
you don't understand.
As his roommate, he gets special privilege because he is family now.
Hey, Sun Tzu.
Like, he's the only one that looks the same out of all the Dynasty Warriors games.
He's like the only one that looks the same.
Everybody else looks so different.
Like, they never changed his design.
Like, they were like, this is perfect.
No, don't change it.
This is perfect.
We've hit perfection for him.
I will.
I'm counting on you.
The fight to protect the Imperial seal from our rivals is far from over.
Now that I think about it, my father was very brave to keep such a thing.
But I suppose that's just the kind of man he is.
After all, they don't call him the Tiger simply because of his prowess in battle.
Once he sets his mind on something, he dashes forth with courage and vigor.
The lesser beasts in his way can't help but clear a path for him.
Indeed, he is an unstoppable force.
He really is.
I think that disregard for danger...
Oh yeah, it's not like someone's gonna die young too.
Wherever my feet take me comes from my father.
I also tend to trip and fall quite a bit along the way.
Woah!
If you're gonna keep foreshadowing, it might become real!
Unlike me, he's always thinking things through.
You should get to know him if you get the chance.
Of course I... Well, if you insist, I'll get to know him.
Alright, it's settled.
Johnny, thank you for the one gifted ship!
Thank you, thank you!
Alright, nice!
It's time to get to know Zhou Yu.
Wait, we're talking to his other brother?
Wait, it's pronounced Sun Quan?
I thought it was Sun Quan!
Oh no, the English dub has fucked me up, guys.
Oh my god, the English dub for these games has fucked up.
Oh, they're pronouncing it wrong.
Okay.
Okay, guys, it's not my fault, is it?
Wait, is Quan or Chan the correct way?
Did he fuck up his own name?
It's Sun Quan?
I fucking knew it!
No, wait, I'm wrong?
I don't know anymore.
I don't know if I'm wrong or he's wrong.
Let's fight together, then.
Okay.
I'll say you will grow stronger.
You will be the oldest Sun person in the entire family.
Oh, his pronunciation is the right one?
Oh my god.
Can't believe it.
He'll always be Sun Quan for me.
Can't believe they made him hot!
No, I don't recognize his voice actor.
He'll be their equal one day.
You're too modest.
Yeah, I just met you.
Like, look at his eyes!
Why do you have green eyes?
Sorry, I have just gone on and on about myself.
Regardless, today has been fruitful.
If it isn't too much trouble, I want to speak with you like this again.
Being with you keeps me from straying from my true path.
Can't stop looking at his eyes.
It's so weird.
I can feel it.
It's so uncanny.
Staring into bro's eyes.
Alright, so there's a reason why I never liked Sun Quan.
And like, it's sort of his voice acting and the way he looked.
So this is what he used to sound like in the past.
Sun Quan.
Dynasty.
Warriors.
This is how he used to sound like and I never liked his voice acting because of it.
Was it this one?
Wait, is it this one?
He sounded so like, shrill.
And I was just like, oh.
Let me check.
What was it?
I'm trying to find... When he screams, it was like...
When he starts yelling, it...
No, where was it?
You know how he sounded super hoarse, too?
What game was it?
What game was it where his voice was super hoarse and everything?
It was like... I can't remember exactly which version it was.
And he... Yeah, he sounded like... No, he actually sounded like a crow.
When he starts yelling, it was like...
It was a 3?
Oh my god.
Is it because of 3 and 4 that made me not like Sun Quan?
I think it could be.
I can't believe it.
That was
how long ago it was, and it made me not like it.
Oh my god, where was it?
Oh my god, I can't find the one where he's yelling.
I'm trying to find the yelling voice line.
When he starts yelling, I hated it.
The first impression... Also, I never liked his character design, too.
His character design was not it for him.
Alright, I can't find it, guys.
He sounds normal.
The ones I found, he sounds normal.
But there is a moment... I swear to god.
There is a moment in Dynasty Warriors when he starts yelling, and I was like...
That ain't it.
He was so goofy to me.
And then I was just like... Oh, and also the beard.
Yeah, the beard did not help him at all.
No, 100%.
I agree.
His beard was not it.
Oh, hey.
It's our student's day.
It's something my father taught me.
I'd like to pass it on to you.
Okay.
The gauntlets.
Do I have enough money yet?
No, I'm still poor.
No.
I'm still so poor.
Why did you take all my money?
I can't afford anything.
Guys, I swear to god.
It wasn't my fault.
He took my money, guys.
Officials are coming to inspect the city.
Oh, it's still just that.
No, I swear to god it wasn't me.
He took it all, guys.
He did that.
Not me.
Is this Chao Chao's one?
Yeah, it is.
Suppression of Yang's province.
Alright, let's do this one.
And then we'll call it here.
I don't want to stream too long today.
My voice needs rest.
We'll do this and then we'll do the routes.
We'll go back to the routes and see who I need to talk to.
They have no clear leader.
Does it lack a commander?
Happy Lu Bu.
Happy life.
Zero, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
We need to take them out one by one until their morale is diminished.
Unlike them, we have a leader.
Our forces will lead by Lord Chao Chao himself.
You know, wait.
Actually, let's...
Let's... Okay, I'm skipping this.
Let's do the routes.
Okay, how do I...
I don't want to do this...
Cancel.
Yeah.
Sorry, I can't fight yet.
I want to do the routes first.
Sorry, let me leave the council.
I'm sorry, you talked a lot.
But like, I'll be back.
I swear to God.
What?
Oh, I have some old coins.
Nice.
I got some rocks.
Okay.
Interactions.
Who do I need to talk to?
Uh... Chang'an?
In the Sili Province.
Okay, I just need to talk to Chang'an.
Sorry, lock...
Okay, Sili Province.
Where's Sili?
Okay.
We gotta go find Chang'an.
Oh, there he is!
So Sili.
Whoa, slow down there, Chang'an.
I like, okay.
I think the funniest is because like, Chinese pronunciation.
We have a set pronunciation of things like the toning.
But in English, we don't.
So it's always funny when like, you can tell that the voice actors are trying to accurately pronounce their own names.
But it always sounds so off when they're trying to mix it with the English pronunciation.
Like, if you talk in full Chinese, it makes sense.
But then, because English has its own way of speaking intonations, it just doesn't match well.
It's like when Toby Fox was like, talking about like, talking about Undertale in Japanese.
And then, he just starts, and then when he spoke in English word, it's so different.
He has the hard shipments.
Wait, what was it?
I forgot what he was trying to talk about, but it was so funny.
The Toho project.
Oh, yeah!
Wait, let me find the Toby Fox Toho project.
It just reminds me of that.
Okay, here we go.
This is Toby Fox, the guy who created Undertale.
I love that!
It's one of my favorites.
I love that.
It's so funny.
And, of course, ZUN's Toho project.
Toho project.
Oh, yeah, it's so...
It just really reminds me of when...
Our face must be truly like you and the great Gengun.
You think so?
No!
I know so.
I've been vying for a thorough discussion with you for some time now.
It reminds me of playing Deltarune when the game's finished.
I don't like it when it's like an ongoing thing and it's like the parts are ongoing.
Oh, he's taking an interest on me.
Because I have to stop and I have to remember what happened last time.
But the game's releases are so long?
The time between releases are so long.
Devoted to restoring peace in the realm.
A survivor of the fallen.
How much do you know?
Wait, I have no memory of it.
Yeah, that's the thing.
There's such a long gap in between Deltarune releases.
The reason why I don't play Undertale is because I watched every playthrough of Undertale.
We did the Sans fight though on stream because that's the most well-known thing.
But the reason why I've never done an Undertale is that I'm not going in blind.
I was a huge fan of Undertale.
I watched every playthrough and I know everything about Undertale.
So that's why I personally don't think I can play Undertale on stream.
Just because I already know what's going to happen and everything.
I know about all the routes and stuff like that.
I'm blind with Deltarune though.
I've never watched really any playthrough or know much about Deltarune.
So I don't mind playing Deltarune only because I don't really know any spoilers about it.
And also the fact that it is still ongoing and everything.
And I've never played it before.
Yeah, I'm not going in blind for Undertale.
How much do you know?
Yeah, how much do you know?
Indeed.
That's about the extent of what I've learned about you.
Pursuing stability.
Relying on the abilities of others.
Living a carefree, unobserved life.
Slowly growing older.
Not going to lie, I'm not expecting you to be a big Undertale fan.
I was mostly a Sans fan.
That's really all I cared about.
And you just persist until you're no more.
Your way of life is totally different though.
And that fascinates me.
Woah, I'm fascinating too.
Sorry, I'm not going to swipe right.
That's what it is.
Yeah, I'm...
I have so many options.
Ding dong.
But I don't want to live reliant on the abilities of others.
I believe we are not too dissimilar.
You and I.
Perhaps that is so.
Oh, I did not expect you to hold back out of politeness.
Woah!
Yeah, that's right.
I'm very forward.
On the one hand, there are those who yearn for such a lifestyle.
On the other, there are those who naturally throw themselves into it.
They seem similar, but are fundamentally different.
It is precisely for that reason that I believe we can form deep bonds together.
I look forward to deepening this relationship.
I feel the same.
Mr. Gong?
Friendship, right?
Oh, sorry.
Mr. Chang.
Sorry, I first named it.
Mr. Chang, it's...
It's friendship, right?
Right, Mr. Chang?
Yeah, friendship.
I haven't, like, done... Okay.
Restores health by 5%.
I need, like, health fucking things.
Okay.
Lose health recovery when using a meat bun.
Oh, I feel like that one is still the best.
Yeah.
The restore thing is still...
Yeah, they were just really good friends, right guys?
Just...
Just good friends, guys.
Just good friends.
Okay, let's see.
Now we can do the Chao Chao one.
Is that the other ones?
Okay, so apparently...
We can pay for Yang...
Yu-Jin with the... Okay, we can...
We can pay for him, but I don't really want to pay for him.
He wants the staff, right?
Okay, spear and staff.
Alright, we'll do staff first.
Where's my staff?
There it is.
92.
Okay, he just wants battle arts, so I do have battle arts for that.
Uh...
Wait, did I fucked it up?
Oh, I did.
Okay, we put this here.
And then... arrow, retribution, what's this?
Whoa!
Wait, that's so cool.
But I don't want to use it.
Actually, no, I should use it.
That looked cool.
Alright.
Okay, nice.
Wait, I have nothing.
Do I have nothing in here?
No, I have the strength pill.
I can put another thing in here...
that I don't use anyway.
Restore his health by 70% for you.
Oh wait, we should get that.
Oh wait, no, we should do this.
Alright.
Finally, we're gonna use the staff.
Uh... where was the Wu thing again?
Where was my battle of siege?
Okay, there you go.
It's the Yang province.
Alright, there you go.
Sorry, I'm back now.
I'm back to actually do this mission now, TaoTao.
Sorry about that.
I had a detour.
With Cheng Gong.
Alright guys, before... actually, before...
Oh, I fucking... oh, they...
Oh, I don't get the battle... okay, that's fine.
We don't need that information.
We just go in.
Okay, so...
Before I go in, I was so obsessed with Sans and Papyrus...
That, like...
You know those parody songs?
Where they use their...
Like that?
I was so obsessed with it.
That I have songs of...
On my iPhone.
Where I download it.
Where they did Drop Pop Candy.
So I'm not gonna play it.
Because I think I'll get demonetized.
Well, I don't know if I'm gonna get demonetized for the other stuff I played.
By the way, let me...
Okay, I'm gonna... I'll link it.
But I was so obsessed that I was listening...
To, like...
But the thing is, I have, like...
A version of them technically singing.
Okay, so...
There's...
Oh my god, I'm, like, listening.
I feel so cringed.
So, I, like...
Unironically...
Listened to these songs.
And they have, like, other stuff.
So I...
Unironically...
Actually enjoyed...
The songs.
There's, like, no lyrics.
They're just going like...
Uh...
So, I actually...
I actually, like...
Saved it on...
I saved it on my phone.
And everything.
So, yeah.
Anyway.
Anyway, back to Dynasty Warriors.
Alright.
Yeah, I wanna know... Actually, I should know what I wanna do.
I, like, skipped that.
Okay, what do I have to do?
Uh... Okay.
Where do I go?
Let's move on to details.
However, staying purely defensive would be a waste of time.
We'll use the terrain to our advantage to seek an opportunity to counterattack.
To a critical location.
The high ground... Okay, I'll get...
I'll go to the right.
By controlling these plants, we can launch a large-scale attack on the enemies en route.
Oh, I'll go to the left then.
Why do I have to go to the left?
Person...
Head towards the high ground.
I request that Lord Chahuyuan handle the forest.
Alright.
Wait...
Why did he take all the flamboyancy?
Of Chahuyuan?
Alright.
We can do this.
I've got the staff.
We can totally do this.
Alright, I'll go this way.
Alright.
It's okay.
We'll be fine.
They don't have names.
You know we'll be fine because they have no names.
Nice.
Get out of here!
It's just that easy!
Okay.
We gotta get this too.
Gotta get the base.
Get over here!
Oh, fuck no!
Not the shadows!
Where do I go?
No!
Not the shadows!
Oh, there it is!
Oh my god, no!
The incense!
They used the incense!
The goddamn incense!
Okay.
Do I have to kill him?
Okay, nice.
I'm trying my best!
I'm using a staff!
Okay.
God, he's so strong!
Did I do it?
Nice!
I did it!
Okay, nice.
I detected sorcery.
Nice.
My base is mine now!
All your bases belong to me!
Okay.
Okay, I'm here to save you!
Don't worry, eat your bread!
Okay,
we just gotta kill him.
Don't worry, count it!
Oh my god!
Why is everybody dying?!
Okay, we gotta help.
Okay, we'll kill him first, and then...
Backstab her with that weapon!
Okay.
Nice, we got him.
Get out of here.
They're throwing rocks?!
Okay, this is bad.
Okay.
This is actually bad.
Alright.
Okay, we gotta go this way.
Oh wait, no, we're throwing rocks!
Oh, thank god!
Thank god!
I was getting worried.
Oh no.
Oh no, I need to save Chow Chow!
No!
Wait, I have to fucking save Chow Chow!
Give me a sec!
There's an entire army heading over!
Give me a sec, I'm trying to- Oh my god!
Okay.
Okay, we made it.
We made it, guys.
We made it.
There's too many things to do!
Jesus Christ.
Why are you guys all so pathetic?!
You had to do everything?!
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god, please!
What do you mean?!
That was your entire job, Chow Chow!
I can't be everywhere!
Oh my god.
I can't be everywhere, what do you mean?!
Okay, we did the- We did that.
And now, okay, we did the- What does Alsace need?
He needs a spear.
Okay, that's fine.
Where's my spear?
Where is it?
Oh my god, it's weaker though.
It's fucking weaker.
Oh my god, he fucking did it.
I'm so proud of him.
He fucking did it.
Alright.
We did it.
Get out.
Get out, I killed all your leaders.
Get out of here.
I killed all of them.
Surely you'll recover now.
Surely you'll be okay.
Alright, now we get this base back.
Okay.
It's fine.
I just need to do this the whole time.
Get out of here.
I just need this base.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Go dragons!
Do something!
That's all I want!
Anything!
Just do something!
Oh my god.
Get out of here.
Just do anything!
That's all I ask!
Oh shit.
You know what?
Fuck it.
I can get it back easily.
There you go.
That's all he did?!
That's it?!
That's fine.
That's alright.
Alright.
Oh shit.
Okay, he's almost dead though.
Oh, you're so strong for someone with no name!
I hate that.
I hate that he actually has no name, but he's so fucking strong.
Like, that's bullshit.
You should not have so much strength in you.
You don't even have a fucking name.
Okay.
Nice.
Okay, nice.
Get counted.
That's fucking right, get counted.
That's right, I'm just using my Y combo.
That's fucking right.
That's right, get over here!
Get over here!
No, exactly!
You have no- You don't have a name!
You should not be that strong!
Okay.
Nice.
Fine.
Explode.
Alright.
Okay, well he couldn't do the simple chorus mission.
That's fine.
I have to go fucking protect- I have to protect fucking Tao Tao and you can't even do that for me.
Yen.
I don't ask for much, Yen!
I don't fucking ask for much!
Just needed you to do one thing for me, buddy!
Just one thing!
Okay.
There you go.
He's dead.
Wait, no he's not.
Now he's dead.
Now he's dead!
He's like literally- No, he's actually in a mosh pit right now.
I gotta try my best to fucking protect him!
Okay.
I guess we'll do the chorus then.
Yeah, Yen's gone.
He couldn't do like one thing for me.
Literally, all we asked was for Yen to do that one thing and he couldn't do it.
Actually, since he's dead already, I might as well- He's dead anyway, so I might as well help Cheng Gong.
Oh, look at that!
I don't even have to help him!
Wow!
Nevermind!
Unlike Yen, he's actually reliable!
Wow!
That's crazy!
He was active!
Good job!
Who would've thought?
Oh god, please.
Please live.
PC, please live.
Please!
I can't do this again!
Oh god.
Every time I get PTSD- No, you guys don't understand.
I get PTSD every time I become a true warrior.
I- I get PTSD every time.
Just a sea of yellow.
That's fucking right!
That's right!
Get absolutely destroyed!
There we go.
Get out of here!
You think you're better than me?!
Get out!
Oh shit, I'm too far.
It's gonna hit them, right?
Please!
Get out!
Oh, nice.
Goodbye!
You are a true- Frozen, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
That's fucking right.
Nice!
We did it.
It's just that easy.
We fucking did it.
We did the thing that Yuan couldn't do.
Wait, what?
God damn it!
Okay, we have to go back.
We have to go back.
We have to- No, please!
Oh my god!
Oh no.
I'm riding my horse as fast as I can.
Oh my god!
Oh my fucking god!
It's like a sea of ants!
What?
Holy shit!
It's like a fucking sea of ants!
That's crazy!
Holy shit!
Give me a sec, everybody!
Oh my god!
Get out!
I can't believe it!
Alright.
That's fine.
We did it.
I don't know how!
Holy shit!
Oh my god!
There's so many of them!
Look at all this fodder!
Holy shit, and he's huge!
That was crazy!
You know what?
I'm getting him in here!
Get over here, Shahutan!
Just kill them all!
Use your rage mode!
That's right!
You made a fucking mistake!
You made a mistake!
I brought in the big boys!
That's fucking right!
Brought in the big boys in here!
You can't prevail!
I am Shahutan with two eyes!
You think you can prevail?
I have two eyes!
Get out of here!
It's over!
No, I can't!
Please!
Please, I just want to stay!
I shall!
Please!
Oh my god!
I'm not letting you regroup!
You think I'm gonna let you regroup?
Get over here!
Get your ass over here!
You live by one HP!
Can't believe he lived with one HP there!
We gotta go to point C.
Nice, alright.
Okay, we gotta go to point C now.
Oh my god, so much- NO!
I didn't mean to fuck!
I was trying to- I was trying to get my horse!
God damn it!
It's okay, we don't need that.
We don't need it, guys.
That's right!
I'm here now!
Okay.
We got this!
There's not a C of them though, so like it's a little harder- Jesus Christ!
Alright.
It is a little harder because there's not a C of them!
Okay.
127!
Alright, that's fine.
Alright.
Oh my god, Chen gone!
Oh my god, please eat up, Ren!
Please!
Jeez, that's dark.
Jesus Christ!
Alright, use your arrows!
Okay, nice, we did it.
Just eat your bread, please!
Oh shit, what the fuck?
Please!
Okay, we just need to kill him.
He seems to be the strongest out of all of them.
Nice!
Get out!
Just gotta kill the strongest guy!
You think you're gonna run?
Get over here!
Oh fuck!
I spent so much time trying to kill you!
Get over here!
I wasted too much time to kill you for you to run!
Coward!
That's right, continue to starve.
Then you keep starving.
He's ruining.
He's ruining!
Alright, let's take this base too.
Just for the fun.
Also, I need to get this.
I need to get this achievement.
Okay, nice.
Nice!
Get out of here!
Jesus Christ, you're so tanky!
If I knew, I wouldn't have fought you!
I wouldn't have let you stay in your house!
Alright, nice.
Oh my god, I wouldn't let him stay if I knew he was this fucking tanky.
Okay, nice.
Get out!
You're cancelled?
That's what, longer already for you?
Alright, nice.
Easy.
Okay.
I need this combo though.
Oh, nice!
2,000!
Oh, please!
Please live!
I don't wanna be a true warrior!
Please!
Please VC, I don't wanna be a true warrior!
I- I swear to god!
Okay, nice, nice.
We completed...
Did we complete all of it?
Nice.
Zero training.
Nice, I didn't have to pay for it too.
Thank god.
Okay, wheels.
Oh, okay.
Junhee wants wheels.
Oh wait, he wants- Wait, did I finish?
Okay, I think- Mounted charge.
And then...
Completed battle arts.
Okay, now I need to use the wheel.
Okay, nice.
My favorite weapon.
At least.
Alright.
Alright, it should be 5.
Was it that- Was it really that it?
Uh, oh wait.
Uh, mounted...
What was the other one?
Battle arts with wheels.
Okay, I can do that.
Wait, I went the wrong way.
Oh wait, I missed that horse stance.
Not gonna lie.
The horse stance- Cause I can like control that horse easier.
Uh, Fuzzy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
If the yellow termans wanted to win...
Uh, they would- I said I'm- General.
Fuzzy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I mean, it's not wrong.
It's not wrong.
Alright.
Do I just have to kill all of them?
Oh my god, I guess I do.
That's fine.
With all my might, let's fucking go.
Jesus Christ.
That is so strong.
That's actually crazy.
How strong that attack is.
Oh my god, they're just dead.
Get over here.
Get outta here.
Oh my god, I might hit 3,000 at this point.
Like, I'm just running in, mowing them down.
Like, I'm literally a long mower right now.
All these poor men who's gonna have widows.
They're just standing there.
They're just letting me send my things out.
Oh shit, wrong one.
Nice.
Alright, get over here.
The mower is here now.
Bye.
These men are amazing for us.
So many widows today.
So many.
Jesus.
Look at all these widows that's gonna happen.
There's more?
Oh my god, they're just standing there.
Ready to be mowed down.
Oh my god, I'm not even halfway.
I'm not even halfway to the large central force.
Like, holy shit.
I'm just swinging.
I'm at 3.
I'm gonna be at 3k.
I am the widow maker.
I shall become the widow maker now.
Okay, there has to be like an easier way to do it.
Okay, there's like a huge patch of people here.
Okay, my new patch of men to mow down.
Nice.
Did I not finish it yet?
How much do I have?
Oh, 100.
Okay, almost there.
Guys, I'm not even halfway.
Wait, I can just kill the officers?
Wait, wait, what do you- Okay, goodbye.
I'm leaving.
I'm going in.
Goodbye.
I'm leaving.
I'm fucking leaving.
Goodbye.
Wait, how do I get there?
Oh, it's right here.
Goodbye.
I'm here now.
I just noticed how low my HP was.
I'm here to mow the lawn.
Get over here.
It's time.
Jesus Christ.
Oh, this is my favorite weapon too.
Get out of here.
You shall be my 3000 kills.
Whoa, what?
Oh, he said that.
Can't starve if you're already dead.
Defeat a thousand enemies?
What else was I doing just then?
Have I not done that?
Oh no.
In two minutes.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Okay, please.
Please, PC.
Please.
Please live.
Oh my god.
I almost have Shao Hu done.
Jesus Christ.
He like...
I'm pretty sure he took over Zhang.
He definitely took Zhang.
He's the bad boy in this there.
Oh my god, please.
I'm so close.
Jesus Christ.
There's so many.
No!
There's so many!
Oh my god!
I'm trying my best.
I'm trying to act my best right now.
Oh my god!
How much grass is there?!
Jesus!
I'm still going!
Oh my god, I'm so close.
Oh my god, we did it!
Jesus Christ.
Oh, thank god.
Please!
Get these boom men outta here!
Oh my god, I can't.
I can't.
I'm 1 HP right now.
Jesus Christ.
I'm gonna use that.
Oh my god, I had to use it.
I had to use it, guys.
I'm actually...
I would have died.
There's so much.
There's so many.
I'm at 3,900.
How?!
Oh my...
They're dead.
They're all dead.
I have killed millions today.
Jordan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
RedCliffWatchLongWin.
Maybe one day.
This is actually one of my favorite movies, though.
Part 1 ends part 2.
You know?
We did it, guys.
We killed millions today.
But we are an agent.
Remember, we are an agent of peace, guys.
What better way to bring peace than with violence?
Nice!
Level up.
Oh my god, 161?
I completed a lot there.
For peace.
For peace, guys.
Nice.
Completed.
I may be able to talk to Junkie.
Alright.
And then...
Boost attack.
Strength.
Defense.
Okay, we definitely need to hold more bugs, though.
Look at all those orphans and widows that we created, guys.
Yeah!
NotSoDeadPool, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki is a Three Kingdoms booty warrior.
Only one type of prize.
I'm kidding.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Look at his puppy dog eyes.
He's like, please don't kill me.
Yeah, but he's different.
Look at him!
He's hot.
Hot people can't commit evil, surely.
If evil, why hot?
Exactly.
Fellas, welcome to The Tomato Farm!
Welcome, welcome!
Society.
One in which we create, protect, and share, rather than live in this endless cycle of stealing.
If you would like to see such a society, then join us.
We will give you all something to live for.
You have my word, as the one who defeated your leader, Zhang Jiao.
You're not- what?!
I defeated his leader!
What are you- what?!
He just took credit?!
What do you mean, you?!
Also, thanks, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Hey, Doki, thanks again for mowing my lawn.
Here's $10, your lawn that's filled with dead people now.
And I'll take down all million of those.
They remain a fighting force, but in peacetime, they mostly train and help in the fields.
Did you get done in this game yet?
But they are dealing with huge numbers of people.
If he is, he'll make this game a 10 out of 10.
Repairing buildings, distributing land ownership, enforcing the law.
To develop so much in such a short time.
Look at that Sima Yi.
He looks less evil.
There's no way!
No!
That's like that Steve Carell meme.
There's no way, I refuse to believe- thank god, I was like, that is not Sima Yi.
If anybody should look evil, it would have been Sima Yi.
Yeah, I was gonna say, that looks like Jun Yu.
I was like, there's no way.
Who's the other guy?
Wait, who's the third guy?
Where did he come from?
That's Guo Jia?
Ji?
Or Jia?
Guo Jia?
It can be fun to watch such a taciturn man loosen up for once.
He has earrings, what the fuck?
Yeah, see, I told you.
Wei has only one Zhou Yu.
Wu has like 10 of them.
Like, that's Zhou Yu- that's blue Zhou Yu right there.
For a moment there, I was ready to die.
Luckily, a house guest of Wan Yun's came to my rescue.
We have blue Zhou Yu at home.
Woah!
Woah, he's shy!
Woah, he's like, oh my gosh!
I am Guo Jia.
I only just met these two at the governor's castle.
If you're here in Puyang, does that mean you've entered Lord Zhou's house first?
He got sober from seeing my face!
Guo Jia.
I'm trying to remember what he looks like.
Oh my god, they added him later, right?
I don't remember- oh my god, I don't remember him.
When did they add him?
When did they add this guy?
He's such a pretty boy.
He added him in 7?
I don't remember him at all.
He's such a- oh my god!
I'm looking at his designs!
And I'm like, what the- guys, look at this design.
Oh my- this is what he looked like before.
I don't remember him.
This is what they did to Zhang.
They took away Zhang.
He's fabulous.
And then just gave it to everybody else.
Oh my god!
Look at this outfit!
What the fuck is this outfit?
Oh my god, he's so- oh my god, with the thigh- with the thigh boots too?
Oh my god!
Wait, look at this outfit.
Look at those boots, guys!
Wait, does he play pool?
Was that his whole thing?
Oh my god, you're right!
His outfit is a pool player!
Looks very historical, guys.
It does.
I was like, who the fuck is this guy?
His weapon was pool sticks.
That's like, hilarious.
Who's this guy?
This is so default.
There's no way he has a name.
What?
It's like, die by trainer and die by the battlefield.
Eugene?
Apologies for inter- you'll lose your men's favorite.
I don't care about him too much.
He looks too default.
Eugene never asked for this!
I think that already happened.
They already outwrote me from several battles.
Tata literally took credit of killing Chengjiao.
It's disappearing in real time, guys.
Did you find some work?
Did you stop being a fucking moocher?
Your housewife?
I mean your doctor.
Thank god!
Are you gonna start paying rent?
My male wife.
Ugh!
I always forget he's my little roommate.
Back to work?
Oh, I'm the work?
Okay, I guess you're not gonna be pay- I'm still gonna pay the full rent, I guess.
I guess I'm still paying the full rent.
That's fine.
That's- that's fine.
My little freeloader.
That follows me around and does nothing.
Oh, a new super chat!
Not Doki.
Thank you for the super chat, novice Chin Soldier.
I was one of the people using magic in- oh, I guess that's what they call it.
Magic in Yang Province.
I should mention that thanks to Lord Tata, I was able to leave my disgraceful past behind and start a new life.
I owe a great deal to him, but I will also never forget the one who taught us how to harness the power of incense.
The way you carry yourself, your aura, that out- that outwardliness about you.
It so reminds me of him.
You two know each other, right?
If you ever encounter him again somewhere, please tell him that we are- Wait, what?
This guy super chatted me to tell Lord Chao Chao that he's grateful for him?
I- Okay.
Okay.
Wow, it's just like my streaming.
I guess thanks for the money, I guess.
He's just like, can you tell Chao Chao that I'm still thinking about him?
Since you're doing a collab with him right now, here's a- Can you pass the message- He's not reading my super chat, so I'm gonna super chat you so you can tell him about my super chat.
Yujin, thank you for the- Yujin, I have something I'd like to ask you.
I apologize for the sudden request, but can you give me a chance to speak with- I guess thanks for the money, though.
Give me a chance to speak with you in person?
There's so much I wish to know about you.
That's taking everything I have to contain my impulse to arrive at your door.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Hey Toki, can you tell him that I'm grateful for his streams?
She's back now!
She's back from Japan!
Thank you, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
But thanks for the money, I appreciate it.
Please come meet me in the city whenever it is convenient- Oh my god, he cannot wait for me.
Oh, okay, he's like- Oh shit, 30?
Let's fucking go.
Nice.
I have- oh my god, I think I might have to use the Oblivion gem.
I'm gonna use the attack, then.
Literally, like, my other gems aren't- My other gems are so underleveled compared to it.
But I like the damage boost, though.
Damage boost is so nice, because I parry a lot.
We'll try the Oblivion gem, since it is higher now.
Alright, who else wants to talk to me?
Alright, is it just- okay, I could pay for- Okay, I have Guo Ji- Jia and Yun Zhen.
Where is he?
Okay, I'm gonna pay for Dian Wei, because I cannot be bothered.
Actually, wait, what was it?
What were the things he wanted me to do, Pantong?
I don't remember.
There was, like, one that I was like, I hate it.
It was...
Oh yeah, it was this.
Yeah, I'm paying for that.
I'll pay for that later.
I don't wanna pay for it now.
Okay, is this the Yang province?
That's Jin.
Where's Yang?
That's Lian.
That's Ji.
That's You province.
That's Jin again.
The fuck is Yang?
Yu.
Shu.
Ji.
Qing.
Oh, no that- Where is it?
Okay, let me find it here.
Hu Ya?
It's in the middle?
Qing.
Yu.
Si Li.
Oh, there it is.
There's Yang.
Okay, I found it.
There he is.
Hey, I did your mission.
Are we going on another food date again?
I feel like all they do is just take me out for lunch.
What do you mean?
I was a little suspi- I was a little suspicious.
Yeah.
Felt like...
I mean, you really want to appear out of nowhere at my doorstep.
This could've been a text!
Yujin, this could- This could've been a text!
I could've wrote a letter!
You could've wrote me a letter!
Oh my god, I still exist here?
They haven't rooted me out yet?
Look, Yujin.
You're not Lu Bu.
I'm sorry.
This could've been an email.
And I wondered if you might have some connection to me.
Oh!
Wait, my past!
He has a connection about my past.
Anyway, I'm trying to learn everything about you.
I hope that's no bother.
Calm do- Calm down, little boy.
I don't remember my- I wanna say this.
I wanna say it.
I was just so excited to meet you.
Of course.
Your memories.
Oh, he backed off.
He was like, oh no, he might not be interested.
He backed off.
He was like, wait, is he not interested?
Slow down, buddy.
Slow down.
I have lots of choices.
Alright, nice.
What's this?
Okay, it's just a weapon shop, but I'm still broke.
You're giving him self-doubt, Toki!
Aw, they changed his shoes!
No more thigh shoes!
Already missed his thigh shoes.
Sounds so young!
What's happening?
They took away Zhang Yi's flamboyantness and then distributed it across the Wu faction.
A favorite of yours.
Wait, is he gonna show Pu?
Is he gonna play Pu?
Sorry, I meant Wei.
I always mix up Wei and Wu because... wait, what?
Wait, what?
But I always mix Wei and Wu because they both started with W and I always mix up the two.
I feel a bit... whoa, wait, what?
Sorry, I just processed what he said.
I feel a bit... what do I say?
Glad to have your expertise?
Okay.
Whoa!
Wait, what?
What?
Wait!
What do you... wait, why don't you want people here to watch?
Whoa!
Okay!
What is this dude?
No, you don't fade to black!
Show me what this dude...
No, you do not fade to black!
What is this dude doing?
Wait, what?
I never wait!
What do you mean fade to black?
Wait, what do we do?
What is this new experience?
What do we do?
What do you mean fade to black?
What do you think?
Are you able to see things differently now?
Our lives pass in a fleeting moment, so we must take time to seek out whatever brings us joy.
You're beginning to understand yourself.
What do we do?
What did we do?
Like, it just fades!
Oh my god!
Okay, alright, I guess we fade to black.
I don't know what happened, but I guess that's the deal.
He said he'll give me a new experience, and then like, he's like, let's go somewhere where there's not a lot of people.
I was like, okay, and then it stops!
That's a good stopping point, guys.
They play Monopoly all night long.
It's just Monopoly, right?
Warrior, peace, and speaker spread out.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Mantra, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
I mean, there was a battle in about 260 BC, China, that had about 700,000 casualties.
The battle changed, and it was all me.
The battle changed, being 450k.
Your KD is alright, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
CFMG, he don't cook, he don't clean, so let him show you how he got better.
Doctor, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Guto, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Justice for Chao Chao, he just wanted to make a world that followed the law.
Better than Lupe, who has no plans, let his allies do everything, and could not even protect his son from falling.
I mean, that's true, though.
Lupe literally had everything to win, but he was just so bad at being a leader.
But yes, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Hey guys, that's a good stopping point, everybody.
I wish I could do a livestream for it, but like, I've just been slowly, gradually getting my voice back in order.
I mean, every day is an improvement, so that's good.
Every day, my voice is getting better and better, so like, I'm glad for that.
It just takes a bit to warm up.
But thank you all for coming!
I always appreciate it, guys.
I hope you guys had a great time on another Dynasty Warriors part.
Part 5 or 6?
I mean, this is going to be a long series, because we're going to do all the factions.
We're going to do Shu, Wei, Wu, and Wu.
So we're going to do all of them.
So it's definitely going to take us a while to finish this, but it's going to be worth it, because this is my favorite series.
This is my favorite game of all time.
Like, not just Origins, but Dynasty Warriors in general is just my favorite series.
Anyway, guys.
Also, Deadpool.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
There's a doujin of 2K Dan and Ciba Tao that shows what they did.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, guys.
As always, everybody.
Oh, yeah.
Before we go, please check out.
We do have official plushies out right now from YouTubes.
I actually... so please check it out.
I'm going to show a little bit, guys, before I go.
But yes, wish to support me.
Please check out these official plushies.
They actually sent me the plushies.
And they're actually really big.
I was very surprised how big they were in general.
And the quality is insane.
I might post a picture of it in the future.
I'll post a picture of it on Twitter.
And also show it on stream later.
And take a couple of pictures.
I think my favorite has to be the tomato.
I love chucking the tomato.
I don't know.
It's very chuckable.
Let me just say.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That's way too common here to be a new experience.
That makes me see the world differently.
Oh, my God.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, guys.
As always, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Also, I'll just say.
The more sales we get on these plushies.
The more opportunities we have in the future.
So it really does mean a lot.
If we can get more.
The more support we can get for these plushies.
Hey, guys.
I'll just say that.
That's all I'll say.
I'll see you guys later, everybody.
I'll say it again.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get that blood flowing.
And if you stayed up for me.
Head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.